WELL GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE.
I'D LIKE TO WELCOME EVERYONE TO
THE JOINT INFORMATIONAL HEARING
ON PAID FAMILY LEAVE --
WITH THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER FOUR AND
LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE --
AND I'LL BE.
RUNNING THE SHOW RIGHT NOW --
SAMBAR COOPER COULDN'T MAKE IT
THIS AFTERNOON --
HOWEVER I DO WANT TO THANK HIM --
FOR JOINING --
WITH OUR COMMITTEE --
IN IN SETTING THIS HEARING UP
AND UNDERSTANDING THE IMPORTANCE.
OF OF THIS ISSUE.
TODAY ABLE HEAR AN OVERVIEW OF
CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING PAID
FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
EXPAND.
THE PROGRAM AND WE CERTAINLY
WANT TO WELCOME AT THE DIRECTOR
HANGING HERE WITH US TODAY.
WE'LL ALSO HEAR FROM A PANEL
STAKEHOLDERS ON THE IMPORTANCE
OF PAID FAMILY LEAVE IN ISSUES
CONSIDERING EXPANDING THE
PROGRAM.
AS CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT I'M HONORED TO CAN BE
IN THIS HEARING ON PAID FAMILY
LEAVE A CRITICAL ISSUE. FOR
CALIFORNIA'S WORKING FAMILIES.
WE TALK A LOT ABOUT THE FUTURE
WORK IN OUR COMMITTEE AND THE
ISSUE OF HOW WE CREATE POLICIES
THAT SUPPORT WORKING MOTHERS AND
FATHERS --
WE KNOW IS RELEVANT AS EVER WERE
HEARTENED BY THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO EXPAND.
PARENTAL LEAVE TO SIX MONTHS.
I HOPE TO LEARN MORE TODAY ABOUT
THAT PROPOSAL BUT I ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT IS DEFINITELY A
WORK IN PROGRESS.
WITH SIGNIFICANT DETAILS TO BE
HAMMERED OUT AS WELL.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE --
WE CAN AND MUST DO MORE TO GET
WORKERS AN OPPORTUNITY TO BOND
WITH AND RAISE THEIR CHILDREN WE
KNOW.
THAT THAT THE CHILDREN'S HEALTH
AND WELL BEING DEPENDS ON THAT
AS WELL.
WELL CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A
LEADER ON THE ISSUE OF PAID
FAMILY LEAVE WE NEEDED WE NEED
TO DO BETTER.
WE NEED TO BETTER ADDRESS THE
DIVERSE NEEDS OF OUR EVOLVING
WORKFORCE.
WE MUST ASK OURSELVES IS ARE
CURRENTLY SISTER SYSTEM MEETING
THE NEEDS OF PART TIME WORKERS
IMMIGRANT WORKERS SINGLE PARENTS
WERE LOW INCOME WORKERS.
I WOULD SAY OF THAT IT'S NOT AND
I BELIEVE THE RESEARCH SUPPORTS
THAT CONCLUSION.
I'M CERTAINLY INTERESTED IN
HEARING OF RECOMMENDATIONS TODAY --
ON HOW TO MAKE FAMILY LEAVE
ECONOMICALLY VIABLE A NOT JUST
FOR THE STATE TO HAVE A
CERTAINLY A FOR ALL WORKERS AS
WELL.
AND I CERTAINLY INVITE ANY OF OF
MY COLLEAGUES TO THE LIKE TO
MAKE ANY COMMENT.
ALL RIGHT --
AND I THINK IT'S IN A RIVER
WICKS AND SHOOT A FOR BEING HERE
I KNOW WILL HAVE AFTERNOON.
AND SO --
WHY DON'T WE BEGIN --
WITH THE DIRECTOR OF OUR
EMPLOYMENT OF EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT.
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT --
PATRICK HEADING.
THANK YOU IS THAT WHEN THE COLOR
AND THANK YOU ASSEMBLY.
PEOPLE --
FOR FOR COMMUNITY HERE MORE A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT FAMILY
THAT'S GOING TO GIVE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW I THINK THAT THE
COMMITTEE DID A GREAT JOB OF A
SUDDEN THAT OUT IN THE COMMITTEE --
DOCUMENTS BUT VERY QUICKLY
CALIFORNIA'S PAID FAMILY LEAVE
PROGRAM ALLOWS --
OVER EIGHTEEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS RECEIVE UP TO SIX
WEEKS OF BENEFITS.
IN A TWELVE MONTH PERIOD.
A TO BOND WITH THE CHILD.
OR TO CARE --
THERE'S A THIRD CATEGORY THAT
WAS ADDED --
LAST YEAR BY --
GOVERNOR BROWN THAT ALLOWS FOR
SOME THE CALLED EXIGENCY.
WHICH IS TO ALLOW FOR FAMILY TO
PREPARE FOR OUR MILITARY
FAMILIES AS THEY ARE ABOUT TO GO
OVERSEAS AND THAT COMES INTO
PLAY.
JANUARY OF NEXT YEAR.
AS WE GET OUR COMPUTER SYSTEMS
EXCEPT --
FOR READY FOR THAT NEW PART OF
THE BENEFIT --
PAID HIM LEAVE IS A PART OF THE
STATE DISABILITY INSURANCE
PROGRAM WHICH ALLOWS THE SAME
TYPE OF WAGE REPLACEMENT FOR
INJURIES --
THAT HAPPENED TO FOLKS OUTSIDE
OF THE WORKPLACE AND SUPPLEMENTS
SORT OF THE OTHER SIDE OF
WORKERS COMP IS WHAT I
OFTENTIMES TELL PEOPLE --
BUT GETTING BACK TO PAID FAMILY
LEAVE --
BONTA CLAIMS THAT THE THE PEOPLE
THAT COMBINED ARE THE BIOLOGICAL
OR FOSTER OR ADOPTIVE PARENT OR
LEGAL GUARDIAN AS WELL STEP
PARENT.
OR SOMETHING ALSO CALLED --
LOCAL PARENTIS WHICH ALLOWS THE
COURT SYSTEM --
TO SET UP THINGS --
THE LIKE OF BOARDING SCHOOLS
THERE TO BE ABLE TO BOND WITH
THE CHILD MAKE SURE THAT THE
CHILD IS MOST COMFORTABLE --
SO FAR AS TO YOU CAN CARE FOR
THE CARE SIDE.
CHILDREN PARENTS PARENT LAWS
GRANDPARENTS SPOUSE REGISTERED
DOMESTIC --
PARTNERS AND I THINK THAT.
THE CARE SIDE OF THINGS WHEN YOU
LOOK AT PAID FAMILY LEAVE --
WELL THE UTILIZATION RATE IN
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO CARE --
IS RELATIVELY LOW --
FRANKLY AS COMPARED --
TO FOR BONDING BUT IT IS IN
AREAS I'M REMINDED OF SAME A
FRIEND FROM THE A. R. P. HERE --
THAT BONDING AS OUR SOCIETY
CONTINUES TO A TO TAKE CARE OF
OUR GREATEST GENERATION.
BUT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ALL
THERE FOR THEM --
IT GIVE THE CARE --
THAT THEY NEED AND THAT WHAT I'D
ALSO SAY THIS IS CHILDREN WHO
OFTENTIMES FIND THEMSELVES MORE
TROUBLE THAN THEY THOUGHT THAT
WOULD GET THEMSELVES INTO.
ALSO TO CARE --
FOR YOUR CHILDREN AS THEY GO
THROUGH A LIFE AND NEED SOME OF
THAT EXTRAORDINARY CARE.
PAID FAMILY LEAVE AS I MENTIONED
IS THE THAT'S THE SORT OF THE
BROTHER OR SISTER --
TO STI THEIR FUNDED THROUGH THE
SAME --
TAXING PROGRAM WHICH IS THAT I I
DID WANT TO MAKE SURE I MENTION
THIS -- THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS MENTIONS IT'S
1% OF FEE ON EMPLOYEES WORKERS.
IT'S ACTUALLY --
A FORMULA --
THAT I GET A CHANCE TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THE MOVES UP AND DOWN --
EVERY YEAR --
AND THIS THE FUND GOES I'M SURE
EL IT WAS AWFUL SO --
MENTION IT --
FLUCTUATES I CAN GO ALL THE WAY
UP TO ONE POINT 5% OF EMPLOYEES
WAGES OFTENTIMES WHAT YOU'LL SEE
IT MARKED DOWN ON YOUR PAYSTUB
IS.
C. S. TI CALIFORNIA --
STATE DISABILITY INSURANCE.
I KERN RAISE ABOUT 1% --
THE TAXABLE WAGE BASE IS ABOUT A
HUNDRED EIGHTEEN THOUSAND WITH --
A MAXIMUM BENEFIT OF ABOUT.
TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLARS A WEEK --
YOU HAVE TO PAY INTO THIS FOR
THE PREVIOUS --
QUARTERS COMING UP A LEADING UP
TO THE PROGRAM --
AND MUST BE OR ACTIVELY LOOKING
FOR WORK.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO CARE YOU
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
THE AUTHORIZATION OF THE PERSON
RECEIVING THE CARE.
AS WELL AS A TREATING PHYSICIAN
THAT WERE GIVING THAT CARE --
AND THEN FOR TO COME TO BONTA
JUST MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
PROOF OF THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN --
THE CHILD AND THE PERSON TAKING
CARE OF THEM.
BUT WHICH REPLACED RATES THIS IS
A NEW -- I
THINK IT WAS THE GOMEZ BILL OF A
FEW YEARS BACK --
THAT ALLOWED --
THE WAGE REPLACEMENT TO GO UP
270% --
BASED ON WAGES AND AND START AT
LEAST 60% OF WAGES.
PLACES LIKE SAN FRANCISCO AND I
BELIEVE LOS ANGELES IS
CONSIDERING --
AND I BELIEVE THAT SOMEBODY
WOMAN --
CONSULTS IS ALSO TAKING THAT
LEGISLATION TO BRING THAT ALL
WITH 2100%.
OF WAGES --
BUT CURRENTLY THOSE OF THE
WEIGHT REPLACEMENT RATES --
THAT WE HAVE NOW.
WE HAVE THE EDT DEBIT CARD --
WORKING WITH OUR PARTNERS BOTH A
BIT OF A AS WELL AS HE SAID TO
MAKE SURE THE PEOPLE GET THOSE
PAYMENTS.
IT'S VERY EASY TO TRANSFER THOSE
MONIES OVERTOOK DIRECT DEPOSIT
TYPE SITUATION IF YOU DON'T WANT
TO DEAL WITH THE DEVIL CARD --
TYPE SITUATION --
SOME FOLKS HAVE BROUGHT UP
CONCERNS ABOUT THAT FEES
OFTENTIMES CHARGE THERE --
WE TOOK --
SOME ACTION TO MAKE SURE SYSTEM
TO IN THE CONTRACT IN ARE BORN
OF THE STATE --
BUT THAT BUT THAT IS ABOUT IT
FROM MY PROPOSAL JUST TO GIVE
YOU A REAL BRIEF OVERVIEW OF IT
I KNOW A LOT OF FOLKS HERE --
ARE VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE THE
THANK YOU A DIRECTOR HANDING AND
JUST.
JUST IN TERMS OF POWER SET THIS
UP THE FIRST PANEL IS GOING TO
BE AN OVERVIEW OF PAID FAMILY
LEAVE IN THE GOVERNOR'S. TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET
AND THEN THE NEXT PANEL WILL
DISCUSS ISSUES CONSIDERING
EXPANDING PAID FAMILY LEAVE SIR
TO CONTINUE WITH THIS FIRST
PANEL WE HAVE DANIELLE BRAND OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
DANIEL GRANTED DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AS DIRECTOR HAVING SAY
THEY STATED CALIFORNIA'S PAID
FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM CURRENTLY
ALLOWS WORKERS TO TAKE UP TO SIX
WEEKS OF PAID FAMILY LEAVE
ANNUALLY. TO CARE FOR SERIOUSLY
ILL FAMILY MEMBER OR A BOMB WITH
A NEWBORN OR NEWLY ADOPTED CHILD
WITH THE CURRENT REACH WAGE
REPLACEMENT RATE OF UP 270% OF
SALARY BASED ON INCOME LEVEL.
THE PROGRAM WHICH IS A COMPONENT
OF THE STATE'S DISABILITY
INSURANCE PROGRAM SUPPORTS CHILD
DEVELOPMENT IN THE CRITICAL
FIRST FEW WEEKS OF LIFE.
PUBLIC HEALTH AND ECONOMIC
RESEARCH SHOWS THE PROVIDING UP
TO SIX MONTHS OF PAID PARENTAL
LEAVE TO BOND WITH THE NEW CHILD
LEADS TO POSITIVE HEALTH AND
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES FOR THE
CHILDREN.
GREATER ECONOMIC SECURITY FOR
PARENTS AND LESS STRAIN.
ON FINDING AN AFFORDABLE AND
FORDING AND THINK CARE.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS COMMITTED
TO EXPANDING THE PAID FAMILY
LEAVE PROGRAM WITH THE GOAL OF
ENSURING THAT ALL NEWBORNS AND
KNEW THE ADOPTED BABIES CAN BE
CARED FOR BY A PARENT OR CLOSE
FAMILY MEMBER FOR UP TO SIX
MONTHS.
IN THE SHORT TERM THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES TO
ADJUST THE RESERVE REQUIREMENT.
FOR THE FUND THAT SUPPORTS THE
PAID FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM.
THIS CHANGE WILL ENABLE THE
STATE TO MAKE A DOWN PAYMENT ON
EXPANDING PAID FAMILY LEAVE IN
THE UPCOMING BUDGET YEAR WHILE
MAINTAINING AN ADEQUATE RESERVE.
OVER THE COURSE OF THE YEAR THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL CONVENE A
TASK FORCE TO CONSIDER DIFFERENT
OPTIONS TO PHASE IN AND EXPAND
THE PAM PAID FAMILY LEAVE TO
ALLOW CHILDREN. TO BE CARED FOR
BY A PARENT OR CLOSE IF FOR UP
TO SIX MONTHS.
THE TASK FORCE WILL CONSIDER
SUCH FACTORS AS COST FUNDING
SOURCE IMPLEMENTS TO IMPOSE
SORRY IMPLEMENTATION TIMELINE
AND OTHER RECENT LESS THAT
LEGISLATION SUCH AS A. B. NINE
AWAIT FOR MEMBER GOMEZ.
AND OPTIONS TO INCREASE PROGRAM
PARTICIPATION AMONG ELIGIBLE
WORKERS AMONG OTHER THINGS.
IN ADDITION THE ADMINISTRATION
WILL CONSIDER OTHER CHANGES
INCLUDING ALIGNMENT OF EXISTING
WORKER PROTECTIONS AND NON
RETALIATION PROTECTIONS TO
INCREASE THE ABILITY OF ALL
WORKERS TO EXCESS THESE
IMPORTANT BENEFITS.
FINALLY I JUST NOT THIS PROPOSAL
STILL BEING DEVELOPED AND I'M
BUT I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS I CAN ANSWER AT THIS
TIME.
THANK YOU THE MOBILE EQUIPPING
THEM TO THE PANEL THE WILL HAVE
QUESTIONS FOR ANYONE ON THE
PANEL.
YES AND THEN --
UP NEXT WE HAVE CHAS ALAMO AND
SAID.
CHRISTIAN KIRSTEIN WITH THE IS A
CHRISTINE.
CHRISTINE BUT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAS ALAMO WITH
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE --
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THAT THE TWO COMMITTEES FOR
INVITING US TODAY ON FOR OUR
TESTIMONY WE PLAN TO COVER A
COUPLE.
SORT OF MAJOR POINTS THAT WE
INCLUDED IN IN A HAND OUT THAT
WE'VE RECENTLY RELEASED THAT
CONSIDERS OPTIONS --
THAT THE STATE WE THINK SHOULD
CONSIDER --
IN EXPANDING PAID FAMILY LEAVE
THAT YOU HAVE THAT HANDOUT
AVAILABLE --
ONE OF THE THINGS WE WANTED TO
LOOK OUT IN A IN THIS HANDOUT
WAS TO COMPARE.
CALIFORNIA'S PAID FAMILY LEAVE
PROGRAM TO LEAVE PROGRAMS IN
OTHER STATES AND TO LEAVE
PROGRAMS OTHER COUNTRIES --
SO BEGINNING FROM THE
INTERNATIONAL PERSPECTIVE --
AS YOU KNOW THE U. S. IS THE
ONLY HIGH INCOME COUNTRY IN THE
WORLD THAT DOES NOT HAVE A
NATIONAL PAID FAMILY LEAVE
POLICY -- SO
OBVIOUSLY WITH THAT IN MIND WE
THINK OF COMPARING CALIFORNIA'S
POLICIES TO THOSE IN OTHER
COUNTRIES --
THE TWO BIG DISTINCTIONS THAT WE
WOULD DRAW IN THE INTERNATIONAL
PERSPECTIVE --
OUR FIRST THAT.
BY AND LARGE OTHER COUNTRIES
TEND TO OFFER LONGER LEAF
DURATIONS AND CALIFORNIA DOES
AND THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE FOR
MATERNITY LEAVE.
BECAUSE IN OTHER COUNTRIES IT'S
MORE OFTEN THE CASE THAT
MATERNITY LEAVES OUR OFFER FOR A
LONG DURATION FOR A LONGER
DURATION I SHOULD SAY RELATIVE
TO PATERNITY LEAVE FOR IN
CALIFORNIA THERE PEOPLE DURATION
SO.
IT'S A BIT DIFFERENT THAN THAN
OTHER COUNTRIES.
THE SECOND DISTINCTION THAT I
WOULD POINT OUT --
RELATIVE TO OTHER COUNTRIES IS
THAT.
OTHER COUNTRIES TEND TO
STRUCTURE THEIR PROGRAMMES
DIFFERENTLY THAN WE DO --
THIS MANIFESTS ITSELF IN A
NUMBER OF WAYS ONE EXAMPLE JUST --
FOR ILLUSTRATION IS CANADA IN
CANADA NEW PARENTS SO THINKING
OF BONDING CLAIMS SPECIFICALLY.
NEW PARENTS CHOOSE BETWEEN TWO
OPTIONS THEY CAN CHOOSE TO TAKE
A SHORTER DURATION LEAVE BUT
RECEIVE A HIGHER WAGE
REPLACEMENT.
OR THEY CAN CHOOSE A LONGER
LEAVE PERIOD AS A LOWER WAGE
REPLACEMENTS OF BASED ON THE
FAMILIES ON CIRCUMSTANCES --
TURNING TO OUR COMPARISON TO
OTHER STATES ON PAGE EIGHT OF
OUR HAND OUT.
WE INCLUDE A FIGURE THAT SORT OF
POSITIONS CALIFORNIA RELATIVE TO
OTHER STATES.
AND AS YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA WAS
THE FIRST STATE IN THE COUNTRY
TO IMPLEMENT PAID FAMILY LEAVE
SENSE THAN. FIVE ADDITIONAL
STATES MOST STATES HAVE
SIMILARLY STRUCTURED PLANS STATE
THEY LARGELY RESEMBLE ONE
ANOTHER --
DESPITE THAT.
A COUPLE THINGS THAT WE WOULD
POINT OUT --
THAT ARE A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
IN CALIFORNIA.
THE STATE'S WAIT REPLACEMENT
RATE IN CALIFORNIA WHICH IS 60%
FOR MOST WORKERS IS TOWARD THE
LOWER END AMONG OTHER STATES.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME THE WEEKLY
MAXIMUM.
BENEFITS OF THE CAP WHICH IS THE
WEEKLY MAXIMUM --
A BENEFICIARY CAN RECEIVE WHILE
ON LEAVE IS MUCH HIGHER IN
CALIFORNIA THAN IT IS IN ANY
OTHER STATE.
SO.
WITH THESE COMPARISONS IN MIND.
THE DECISION THAT THE
LEGISLATURE FACES OVER THE NEXT
COUPLE OF MONTHS REALLY IS FIRST
AND FOREMOST WHETHER TO EXPAND
PAID FAMILY LEAVE.
AND SECONDLY IF.
SO HOW TO GO ABOUT DOING THAT.
AND SO IN THINKING ABOUT THE
LATTER HOW ONE WOULD GO ABOUT
EXPANDING LEAVE WE REALLY
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE. TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT IT HOPES TO
ACCOMPLISH BY EXPANDING LEAVE.
AND THEN TO CONSIDER AND PUT
INTO PRACTICE THE BEST POLICY
OPTIONS RIGHT TO SAY THE MOST
EFFECTIVE POLICY OPTIONS THAT
COULD ADDRESS WHAT YOU HOPE TO
ACCOMPLISH --
FOR INSTANCE ARE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL IT'S BEEN PRETTY CLEAR
AND IDENTIFYING EARLY CHILDHOOD
DEVELOPMENT AS THE PRIMARY USE
OF MOTIVATING FACTOR.
AND FOR THAT IN ORDER.
TO ADDRESS THAT GOAL THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED CONCEPTUALLY
TO EXPAND THE DURATION OF LEAVE.
AND ALSO TO MAKE LEAVE MORE
FLEXIBLE.
NOW ON THE OTHER HAND THE
LEGISLATURE PRIMARY MOTIVATION
OR GOAL MAY BE DIFFERENT --
FOR INSTANCE IF LEGISLATORS
PRIMARILY CONCERNED WITH THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO USE PAID
FAMILY LEAVE SO.
THE TAKE UP RATE FOR THE STATE'S
CURRENT PROGRAM.
EXPANDING THE DURATION OF LEAVE
MIGHT NOT BE THE MOST EFFECTIVE
POLICY WE THANK.
ALTERNATIVELY THE LEGISLATURE
COULD.
SERVE CONSIDER OPTIONS TO
INCREASE OUTREACH SO THAT
AWARENESS IS IMPROVE THE PROGRAM
OR POTENTIALLY CHANGES TO THE
WEIGHT REPLACEMENT RATES THINGS
THAT ARE MORE IN LINE WITH WHAT
WE THINK COULD DRIVE --
HIGHER TAKE UP RATE THAN THAN WE
AND AND WE ALSO WANTED TO LOOK.
AT OPTIONS FOR FUNDING PAYING
FOR AN EXPANDED --
POLICY.
AND AT THIS PRELIMINARY STAGE
MINDFUL THAT WE'RE STILL VERY
EARLY ON IN THE GOVERNOR'S IS
PROPOSING TO FORM A TASK FORCE
TO CONSIDER THESE OPTIONS.
OUR OFFICE DIDN'T SCORE A
SPECIFIC.
OPTION OR A SCENARIO --
WITHIN SCORE THE GOVERNOR'S
CONCEPTUAL PLAN FOR ISN'T FOR
INSTANCE WE TOOK A BIT.
OF A BROADER LANDS APPROACH AND
WE ASKED OURSELVES. FOR THINKING
ABOUT THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATIVE
STRUCTURE SO YOU HAVE THIS.
THE PAYROLL TAX RATE THAT CAN
MOVE UPWARDS AND DOWNWARDS BASED
ON THE AMOUNT OF BENEFITS THAT
ARE GOING OUT IT'S CAPPED AT ONE
POINT 5% WE SET OURSELVES.
HOW MUCH COULD BENEFITS INCREASE?
WITHIN CURRENT LAW WITHOUT
MAKING CHANGES TO LAW AND ALSO
STAYING UNDER THE ONE POINT 5%
CAP.
AND WE THINK.
THAT.
PAYROLL TAXES COULD INCREASE
WITHIN THE CURRENT STRUCTURE. TO
SUPPORT AT LEAST ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL BENEFITS.
NOT LIKELY MORE THAN TWO BILLION
NOW -- EACH
YEAR AND AND PAID FAMILY LEAVE
BENEFITS.
AND WE THINK THIS IS SORT OF A
USEFUL BENCHMARK THIS ONE TO TWO
BILLION MARK --
KNOWING THAT CURRENT PAID FAMILY
LEAVE BENEFITS EACH YEAR ARE
ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS IT JUST
PROVIDES OUT ROUGH ORDER OF
MAGNITUDE AS TO WHAT THE SERVER.
POTENTIAL OF THE EXISTING FINING
WE NEED TO MAKE ANY MAJOR
CHANGES --
THAT SAID.
AND EXPANSION THAT GOES BEYOND
THAT AMOUNT.
WOULD OBVIOUSLY REQUIRE THE
LEGISLATURE TO IDENTIFIED
ALTERNATIVE FUNDING SOURCE OR
CHANGE STATE LAW TO A SERV.
MAKE CHANGES TO THE THE EXISTING --
ADMINISTRATIVE STRUCTURE TO
ALLOW FOR ADDITIONAL BENEFITS --
WITH THAT I'LL TURN NOW TO MY
COLLEAGUE SET TO FINISH OUR
PRESENTATION.
SEC KIRSTINE LA --
THE LAST FEW PAGES OF OUR
HANDOUT DESCRIBES SOME OF THE
POTENTIAL EFFECTS OF EXPANDING
PAID FAMILY LEAVE FOCUSING.
PRIMARILY ON THE EFFECTS OF
LENGTHENING LEAVE BENEFITS --
WE DON'T MEAN TO SUGGEST THAT
LENGTHENING WE'VE BENEFITS IS
NECESSARILY PREFERABLE TO OTHER
OPTIONS SUCH AS MY COLLEAGUE
REFERRED TO LIKE RIP.
INCREASING THE REPLACEMENT RATE --
THAT SERVE WHICH OPTION IS WORTH
PURSUING SIR DEPENDS ON THE
LEGISLATURE'S GOALS AND HOW
THOSE LINK UP TO THE DIFFERENT
POLICY OPTIONS THAT ARE BEFORE
YOU -- THE
MAIN REASON WE FOCUS ON ONE
THING BENEFITS IS SIMPLY THAT
THAT'S THE OPTION THAT'S BEEN
STUDIED THE MOST EXTENSIVELY IN
THE LITERATURE --
I'LL HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE SETS OF
FOR FACT OF LEAVE BENEFITS ON
PARENTS EMPLOYMENT WE
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN SHORT TERM
EFFECTS AND LONG TERM EFFECTS.
SO THE SHORT TERM EFFECTS WELL
PARENTS ARE UNDER THE AGE OF TO
ARE UNCERTAIN WITH SOME EVIDENCE
POINTING TOWARD SUBSTANTIAL
INCREASES IN PARENTS EMPLOYMENT.
AND OTHER EVIDENCE POINTING
TOWARDS MINIMAL AFFECTS. ONE OR
TERM THE EVIDENCE SUGGESTS THAT
THE EFFECTS OF ON PARENTS
EMPLOYMENT BEYOND.
THE FIRST COUPLE YEARS OF THEIR
KIDS LIVES WOULD LIKELY BE
PRETTY SMALL.
TURNING TO THE EFFECT ON KIDS WE
FIND IT SIMILARLY USEFUL TO
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN SHORT TERM
AND LONG TERM AFFECTS.
ALL LONGER LEAVE BENEFITS LIKE
WE WOULD IMPROVE INFANTS HEALTH.
AT THE SAME TIME THE LONGER TERM
EFFECTS ON THE KIDS HEALTH
EDUCATION AND LABOR MARKET
OUTCOMES ARE.
UNCERTAIN WITH SOME EVIDENCE
POINTING TO SUBSTANTIAL EFFECTS
AND SOME EVIDENCE POINTING TO
MINIMAL EFFECTS SO THAT
CONCLUDES OUR TESTIMONY AND WE'D
BE HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS IF
YOU HAVE ANY.
THANK YOU ALL OF ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS --
WORKS THANK YOU I THANK YOU FOR
PRESENTING TODAY I'M.
THE MOTHER OF A TWO YEAR OLD A
BIG SUPPORTER OF PAID LEAVE I
UNDERSTAND HOW IMPORTANT THAT
THAT EARLY TIME WITH YOUR FAMILY
REALLY IS --
ESPECIALLY YOUR BRAND NEW
PARENTS --
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS I HAD IS --
JUST CONCERN AROUND --
THIS THE FACT THAT I THINK ARE
LOW WAGE WORKERS ARE NOT --
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROGRAM AS
MUCH AS WE WANT TO SEE BUT ALSO
I WANT TO TALK SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT.
GIGA CONNIE WORKERS --
AND THE CHALLENGES THERE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS IS IS GOOD
ECONOMY WORKERS MANY OF WHOM I
THINK --
MISCLASSIFIED AND WE HAVE
CHALLENGES AROUND SAME KIND OF
PROTECTIONS --
THAT OTHER WORKERS HAVE AND THAT
FOR PAID LEAVE THEIR UNDER A
SEPARATE PROGRAM IS THAT RIGHT
IS THAT THE DISABILITY INSURANCE
SELECTIVE COVERAGE.
YEAH DEC MY UNDERSTANDING IS
WITH THAT PROGRAM MOST.
YOU KNOW INDEPENDENT CONTRACT
WORKERS --
COULD GET COUNTY WORKERS DON'T
EVEN KNOW THAT IT EXISTS --
I SAW A STUDY THAT SAID IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN OF THE TURN
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND WORKERS
CLASSIFIEDS IS ONLY THIRTY TWO
DECIDED.
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM.
THIRTY TWO WORKERS --
SO.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES.
YES AGREEING ON THAT --
YOU KNOW THEY DON'T KNOW ABOUT
IT THERE'S IT'S IT'S CUMBERSOME
THERE'S MANY STEPS --
AND AGAIN MANY THESE WORKERS I
THINK OUR MISCLASSIFIED AND NOW
WE HAVE OTHER PENDING
LEGISLATION TO HELP RECTIFY THAT
ISSUE -- BUT
IS THIS SOMETHING THAT THAT YOU
ALL ARE ADDRESSING IT THINKING
ABOUT HOW WE CAN PROVIDE THOSE
TYPES OF PROTECTIONS BECAUSE
THESE ARE TEND TO BE LOWER WAGE
WORKERS --
TEND TO BE WOMEN OF COLOR TEND
TO BE PEOPLE THAT YOU KNOW WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
GETTING THE BENEFITS THAT THEY
DESERVE.
BUT THE SOMEONE WHICH I WOULD
SAY THAT --
WE HAVE DONE SOME WORK BUT IT'S
NOT NEARLY ENOUGH.
FRANKLY --
IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR WHEN THE
PROGRAM STARTED --
THE LIGHTS IN THE STATE WERE
STARTING TO FLICKER ON THE
ECONOMICS WERE DOWN --
IN THE GOVERNOR AT THE TIME AND
THEN SUBSEQUENT GOVERNOR.
DIDN'T PUT.
ANY MONEY TOWARDS OUTRAGE.
SO WE STARTED A PROGRAM WITH
VERY LITTLE FUNDS --
IT'S PRIMARILY A MANUAL PROCESS
EVEN TO THE STATE BECAUSE OF
THAT THAT LENDS ITSELF TO SOME
OTHER PROBLEMS.
BUT WITHOUT BUT DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION OF ALL SORTS OF
DIFFERENT GREAT IDEAS --
BUT I BELIEVE IT WAS A COUPLE
YEARS BACK WE RECEIVED ABOUT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS THROUGH SOME
WORK OF SOME OF THE ADVOCATES --
HERE LATER ON TODAY TO START TO
DO SOME OF THAT WORK A SOMEBODY
WHO I KNOW WHO HAS DONE MEDIA
BUYS AND KNOWS THAT WORLD. SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T GET YOU VERY
FAR -- SO
WE'VE DONE SOME WORK --
WE'VE DONE A LOT OUT REACH TO
OUR COMMUNITY PARTNERS I THINK
THAT'S WOULD BE WHAT I WOULD
CALL THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
WORK THAT WE DID --
WE STARTED TO DO SOME VERY
TARGETED THAT'S OF THINGS --
BUT WHAT I WOULD SAY IS --
THERE IS STILL A LOT OF WORK TO
BE DONE QUICKLY TO THOSE LOW
WAGE WORKERS WE HAVE DONE SOME
WE HAVE SEEN INCREASES.
NOT ONLY IN THE TARGETED AREAS
OF LOS ANGELES THE HAS A LOW
UPTAKE RATE I THINK THAT
REFLECTS WHAT YOU SAW THE LA
OWES REPORT --
AS WELL AS A MINORITY --
LATINO AND AFRICAN AMERICAN
POPULATIONS --
BUT THEN ALSO --
FRANKLY FATHERS --
IN TRYING TO GET THE UP TOOK A
FATHER'S BEEN MORE INVOLVED IN
THE FAMILY.
AWAY FROM WHAT --
THIS IN ANTIQUATED VIEW OF THE
FATHER'S ROLE IN THE FILM.
LIKE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS AND
OTHERS ON THIS PANEL AS A FATHER
OF A THREE YEAR OLD --
THIS IS A TOPIC THAT IT'S VERY
CLOSE TO HOME I DO HAVE ONE
FOLLOW UP QUESTION AROUND
OUTREACH --
YOU MENTIONED THE CHALLENGES
WITHIN THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
LATINO COMMUNITIES I'LL TELL YOU
THIS CONCEPT OF PAID FAMILY
LEAVE IS REALLY NOT A DISCUSSION
OF THE API COMMUNITY.
EXCEPT FOR WITHIN WELL EDUCATED
NOT SOMETHING THAT A LOT OF MORE
RECENT API IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES
ARE TALKING ABOUT --
WHAT SORT OF EFFORTS HAVE BEEN
MADE IN THE API COMMUNITY I CAN
A MORE THAN HAPPY TO SHOW YOU
EXACTLY WHAT WE HAVE WHAT WE'VE
DONE I DIDN'T MEAN TO CALL THOSE
TO TWO PARTICULAR COMMUNITIES IN
AS MUCH AS?
THOSE WERE LARGER TARGETS
BECAUSE OF THE POPULATION
DEMOGRAPHICS --
AND STUDIES THAT WE DID LEADING
UP TO DOING THE OUTRAGE AND
SPENDING THE ABOUT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO DO --
BUT I'M MORE THAN HAPPY SOMEONE
TO TO SHOW YOU WHAT WE DON'T FOR
THE API COMMUNITY LOVE TO LEARN
AT THIS POINT OUR POPULATION IS
12% AND GROWING SO --
IT AND AND I THINK RELATED TO
THAT WHAT IS YOUR RECOMMENDATION
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PERSPECTIVE OF WHAT WOULD BE THE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL ABOUT REACH.
TO BE SPENDING THIS YEAR HAS
HAPPENED CITED YET.
THERE ARE NO AMEND I WOULD LOVE
FOR DEAL LEFT TO TALK ABOUT IT
BUT WHAT I WOLD TELL YOU --
IS THAT THERE ARE NO --
FUNDS SET ASIDE FOR OUR EACH
OTHER THAN --
GENERAL ADMINISTRATION OF THE
PROGRAM AND I WOULD SUGGEST AND
HOPE THAT THAT IS A PORTION OF
THE BUDGET AS WE MOVE FORWARD --
I WANT TO SHIFT FROM A TO THE LA --
DISK WE FOUND YOUR ANALYSIS OF
WHAT'S HAPPENING OTHER COUNTRIES
TO BE INCREDIBLY INFORMATIVE I
THINK WE ALL KNOW THAT --
AMERICA'S WAY BEHIND WHAT OTHER
COUNTRIES ARE DOING IN THIS AREA
AND YOU SAY TO THE FACT THAT
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF STUDIES IN
THIS AREA.
HAVE A ANY STUDIES WERE COULD
YOU GIVE US A SENSE OF WHAT HAS
BEEN CONCLUDED AROUND THE
INVESTMENT AND PAID FAMILY LEAVE
AND HOW THAT IMPACTS.
LONGER TERM EXPENDITURES WHEN IT
COMES TO OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM
OUR EMPLOYMENT SYSTEM OR SOCIAL
SERVICE SYSTEM.
I THINK WE ALL AND TO REALLY
BELIEVE THAT THE DOLLARS THAT WE
INVEST TODAY AT THE EARLY AGE
WITH PAID FAMILY LEAVE AND
CHILD
CARE AND EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION --
HAS ENORMOUS DIVIDENDS LONGER
TERM BUT I HAVEN'T SEEN ANY
INFORMATION ABOUT THAT AND GIVEN
HOW MUCH WOOD SPERRY THERE IS I
WAS ONE IF YOU COULD SHARE THAT.
SURE THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SO --
IN TERMS OF THINKING ABOUT THE
LONG TERM FISCAL IMPASSE LONG
TERM OUTCOMES ON THE KIDS AT
LEAST SORT OF THAT --
SORT OF IN THE IN THE MAIN WAY
THAT PEOPLE MIGHT THINK ABOUT IT
THERE MAY BE OTHER CHANNELS TO
BUT I THINK THAT SORT OF ONE
THAT THAT PEOPLE MIGHT THINK
ABOUT FIRST.
FIRST AND I THINK SORT OF WHAT
WE IT BRIEFLY MENTION IN THE
HANDOUT IS SORT OF THE MAGNITUDE
ANSWER BASED ON THE RESEARCH AS
AS WE'VE VIEW IT --
THE LAW OF THE MAGNITUDE OF
THOSE EFFECTS ARE PRETTY
UNCERTAIN SO CERTAINLY TO THE
EXTENT THAT --
THAT THERE COULD BE A LARGE --
LONG TERM BENEFITS THEN
POTENTIALLY THERE COULD BE SOME
KIND OF A SAVINGS OR OTHER
BENEFITS REALIZE BUT BUT TO US
THE EVIDENCE IS AND ALL THAT
CLEAR THAT THAT DOES AFFECT OUR
LARGE OR OR WHETHER THEY COULD
POTENTIALLY BE.
MINIMAL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SOME OF HIS
OFFICE.
SO I I WANT --
TO OBVIOUSLY LOW INCOME WOMEN
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS DON'T
HAVE REALIZE THIS BENEFIT THE
SAME NUMBERS AS OUR COHORTS
ANOTHER.
CLASSES I GUESS --
HAS THERE BEEN ANY --
I I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
CONJECTURE ON OUT REACH AS WELL
AS INCOME REPLACEMENT --
AS WELL ASSINGLE PARENTS VERSUS
A TWO TWO PARENT HOUSEHOLD WHICH
MIGHT HAVE LEAD TO THE
FLEXIBILITY OF BEING ABLE --
TO TAKE TIME OFF WITH A SMALLER
BUT HAS THERE BEEN ANY STUDIES
TO ACTUALLY ASK THESE WOMEN WHO
ARE NOT EDITED OR MAN BUT I'M
I'M.
PRIMARILY CONCERNED WITH SINGLE
MOMS -- IN
LOW WAGE JOBS WHO HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO UTILIZE THIS FOR THE
REASONING WHY.
DO YOU KNOW OF ANY.
I DON'T KNOW ANY PARTICULAR
ROUTE THE TOP OF THE HEAD I
THINK I'LL DO THE CAPTION LATES
IT.
KIND OF WELL IS THAT THERE IS A
WIDE BREADTH OF STUDY.
ON THE SUBJECT I I CAN'T PREDICT
POINT TO A PARTICULAR ONE I
THINK THAT THE POINT THAT YOU'RE
KIND OF GETTING AT IS.
THIS IS A TAX ON WORKERS AND SO
YOU'RE YOU'RE LOOKING AT THAT 1%
AS AN AWFUL LOT PARTICULAR AT
THE LOWER WAGE SCALE RIGHT --
PLACES LIKE THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO HAVE --
SUPPLEMENTED THE REST OF THE WAY
TO FROM EMPLOYER TAXES THAT CAN
KHALEEL ALSO MENTION.
OTHER COUNTRIES AND SOME OF THE
OTHER STATES.
AND WHILE CALIFORNIA --
MAY SEEM LIKE IT'S BEHIND IN
SOME AREAS --
THEY OFTENTIMES WHAT YOU'LL SEE
IS A BLENDED.
TAX STRUCTURE WHEN IT COMES THIS
IN RIGHT NOW --
SYSTEM IT IS SOLELY FUNDED BY
WORKERS.
AT SOLELY FUNDED BY THE FIRST
HUNDRED EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS A WORKER MAKES CREDIT SO
WHILE -- THE
THE ACTUAL PERCENTAGE OF YOUR
INCOME THAT IS PAID IF YOU'RE
MAKING SAY --
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY SIX THOUSAND
BECOMES FAR LESS THAN THE PERSON
THE PERCENTAGE OF THE INCOME
THAT THEY'RE MAKING AN EVEN A
HUNDRED EIGHTEEN THOUSAND THEM
HALF HALF THE AMOUNT OF THEIR
INCOME.
THE CLEAR DEFINITION OF A
REGRESSIVE.
TAX CHANGE.
AT THAT LEVEL THAT HAD THE
BENEFIT IS CAPPED AT ABOUT
TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLARS SO YOU DO
HAVE A CAP OF THE BENEFIT THAT
YOU CAN RECEIVE FROM.
AT TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLARS --
WHICH YES WHICH IS ABOUT WHAT
SIXTY SEVEN THOUSAND MORE IN A
YEAR -- MY
CONCERN AND I'VE BEEN VERY
HONEST I RESERVE A BILL ON IT IS
IS THAT --
LOW INCOME FOLKS BEEN PAIN
THAT'S NOT UTILIZING AND
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED --
AS WE RECOGNIZE AS A BODY THAT
WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO INCREASE
THE MINIMUM WAGE BECAUSE PEOPLE
CAN'T LIVE ON ON WHAT IS IN A
MINIMUM WAGE --
AND YET NOT REALIZING THAT THAT
THEM WOMEN TAKING PARTICULARLY
SINGLE WOMEN TAKING TIME OFF TO
IT TO A CHILD AT 770% OF MINIMUM
WAGE.
IS PROBABLY NO MORE DURABLE THAN
NOT RAISE THE MINIMUM WAGE IN
FIRST PLACE --
SO I I JUST A ALTHOUGH OUT REACH
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THAT
SOMETHING THAT I THINK HAS TO BE
AND ALSO IN THE HANDS OF HUMAN
RESOURCES AT INDIVIDUAL
COMPANIES NEED TO PROVIDE SOME --
GOOD GUIDANCE TO WORKERS BUT
THAT PERCENTAGE I THINK I'M I'M
JUST CONCERNED OF OF WHAT'S
REALISTIC AND I KNOW THAT OTHER
STATES HAVE GONE FURTHER --
GETTING I THINK AS FAR AS 90% OF
INCOME.
I WILL TELL YOU --
INTO SOME OTHER STATES REACH
VERY HIGH AND I THINK NEW YORK
IS LOOKING AT MY MEMORY SERVES
ME CLOSE TO A 100% --
BUT AGAIN IT'S A BLENDED TAX
STRUCTURE --
I WILL TELL YOU I AND I KNOW
IT'S A SMALL STEP FORWARD BUT
FRANKLY FOR A PROGRAM THAT.
IS ABOUT FIFTEEN YEARS OLD --
AND WITH THE SUPPORT THAT IS
RECEIVED OVER THE YEARS --
THE THAT IT HAS DONE A MISSION --
I AM VERY PROUD THAT THIS
GOVERNOR HAS TAKEN A LOT OF
STEPPED IN FACT FRANKLY FOR THE
FIRST TIME --
IN MY HISTORY WITH THIS PROGRAM
AND I WAS THERE WHEN GOVERNOR
DAVIS SIGNED IT --
TOOK A FEW YEARS OFF THERE IN
THE MIDDLE AND AND BACK UNDER
GOVERNOR BROWN AND GOVERNOR NEW
SOME -- VERY
PROUD THAT WE'VE TAKEN STEPS
THAT FOR THE FIRST TIME JUST
LAST COUPLE WEEKS AGO WE MET
WITH HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION.
AND THEY'RE TAKING A VERY ACTIVE
ROLE IN TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HIT THOSE FIRST TIME MOTHERS
THAT.
THAT TO ME THAT'S THAT WHO THAT
NUCLEAR PLACE IF WE CAN GET TO
THOSE MOTHERS WE CAN GET TO
THOSE FAMILIES WHEN THEY FIRST
COME TO THE DOOR TO LET THEM
KNOW.
THESE ARE BENEFITS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO THEM THIS IS NOT A
A GOVERNMENT HANDOUT IT'S NOT
EVEN A A TAX PAID TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT EVENTUALLY TRICKLES BACK
DOWN TO THEM THIS IS A DIRECT
FEE THAT THEY PAY FOR THIS
PROGRAM --
AND WE HAVE TO DO OUR BEST TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
NO SITE I SHARE YOUR PASSION FOR
THAT SOMEONE.
IF YOU FINISH YOUR SNACK A
SUMMER JONES SAWYER.
YES I'M FINISHED WITH MY SON AND
WHEN SHE WANTS TO GO AHEAD.
JUST SO YOU KNOW AT SOMETHING
STUCK IN MY THROAT THE NURSE
RECOMMENDED I OF SO.
SO SO MY DAUGHTER JUST JUST
RECENTLY ABOUT A YEAR AGO HAD MY
GRANDSON.
AND I REMEMBER SITTING TALKING.
TO MY SON IN LAW.
ABOUT ANYWHERE FOR PRIVATE
SECTOR MY DAUGHTER WORKS REALLY
UST AS A TEACHER.
AND AT MY DAUGHTER AND I WORK
FOR THE CITY OF LA FOR QUITE
SOME TIME HIGH DAUGHTER AND I
STARTED COMPARING HOW MUCH TIME
I HAD OFFER PATERNITY LEAVE AND
THIS IS REALLY ABOUT MEN AND
PATERNITY LEAVE AND WE WERE
GOING BACK AND FORTH ABOUT.
YOU KNOW I COULD TAKE THIS DAYS
OFF AND I CAME BACK WHEN I
ALMOST WHEN I WANTED TO IT WHICH
IS.
KIND OF SEAMLESS WHEN WE TALK TO
MY SON IN LAW.
AS A MALE.
TRYING TO BOND WITH HIS WITH HIS
SON -- THEY
TOLD MAYBE IT TO WAIT A WEEK SO
IF YOU KNOW THE EARLY DATE THE
EARLY TIME IS THEN AND THEY
EXPECTED HIM. TO DELAY HIS
BINDING BECAUSE THAT'S A MALE
THING. TO DO AND IT HAD PROBABLY
AT THE MANAGERS THAT GO BACK TO
THE STONE AGES.
BACK TO THE FIFTIES WHEN.
WHEN --
MENDED TAKE OFF OR EVEN BOND WAS
DENIED BECOMING CONCERNED
BECAUSE SEEM LIKE THEY FROWNED
UPON.
HIM WANTING TO SPEND SOME TIME
WITH HIS FAMILY --
AND I BEEN READING THROUGH THIS
ICE SAW A LOT OF THINGS
MENTIONING WOMEN AND THEIR
CHILDREN I DIDN'T SEE A WHOLE
LOT OF THAT ABOUT.
WHAT ARE WE DOING TO MAKE SURE --
PATERNITY LEAVE THIS IS FAIR AND
EQUAL EQUAL OUT.
WHETHER YOUR PUBLIC SECTOR
PRIVATE SECTOR EVEN ACROSS
DIFFERENT LINES WE HAVE A
COLLEAGUE THAT'S OUT RIGHT NOW
THAT HOPEFULLY WE RETURNING.
AND NEXT MONTH.
AND NO ONE'S EVEN THOUGHT ABOUT
HAVING HIM COME BACK EARLY ARE
OR HE NEEDS TO DO THIS OR HE
NEEDS TO DO THAT BECAUSE I'M IN
AND I'M IN AN ENVIRONMENT.
THAT PRAISES AND SUPPORTS UP
PATERNITY LEAVE --
SIDE I DON'T KNOW IF WE'D EVEN
LOOKED AT WAYS WE CAN MAKE
ENSURE THAT PUCK TOURNEY THE
LEAF.
IS SOMETHING THAT IS.
THAT WILL HELP LAND BOND WITH
THEIR WITH THEIR YOUNG CHILDREN
AND THAT THEY HAVE KIND OF THE
SAME.
RIGHTS AND BENEFITS OR IF THERE.
THERE'S SOME PREJUDICE TOWARDS
THEM DO DOING THAT IF THERE'S
ANY SAFETY VALVES AND THAT OR WE
JUST AT THE WHIM FROM.
COMPANY TO COMPANY A COMPANY A
COMPANY OR THIS AGENCY DOES
SOMETHING DIFFERENT THAN THE
OTHER AGENCY --
LIKE I SAID MY DAUGHTER AND I
WERE WE'RE TALKING AS IF.
I HAD THE SAME BENEFITS AS HER
AND WOULD IS AGO WHEN WHEN I HAD
HER AND SO IT'S IT'S A IT'S IT'S
A IS IT JUST.
ME TWENTY YEARS AGO WHEN I HAD
HER IT JUST IT JUST AMAZING TO
ME HOW --
IT'S AMAZINGLY DIFFERENT.
I AGREE THAT MISTER JONES SAWYER
FACT I I'VE BEEN PROUD THAT
WE'VE TAKEN SOME OF THE MONEY AS
I MENTIONED EARLIER TO DO
OUTRAGE AND WE'VE ACTUALLY SEEN
THE LARGEST INCREASE --
IN --
FATHERS.
STARTING TO TAKE LEAVE AND I
WILL TELL YOU I I BELIEVE IT'S
ACTUALLY MORE OF THAT STIGMA.
A CULTURAL IN SOCIETY THAT IS
VERY HARD FOR GOVERNMENT TO
CHANGE ATTITUDES ABOUT.
BUT IT IS A WORTHWHILE PRACTICE --
HOW WE ACTUALLY HAVE SOME --
COMMERCIALS THAT WE DID
PARTICULARLY AROUND THAT THAT
I'D LOVE TO BE ABLE.
TO YES YES --
JUST SO YOU CAN GET A SENSE THAT
BUT BUT YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT
IT'S A LOT MORE AROUND CULTURE --
WORKPLACE PROTECTIONS I'D LOVE --
TO SAY THAT --
MUCH LIKE A LOT OF THE UNION
WORKPLACES I WORKED IN VALUE --
THE SIMILAR TYPE BENEFITS FOR
BOTH OF MALE AND FEMALE WORKERS
BUT OFTENTIMES THAT'S NOT THAT
THINK THAT LA --
SPOKEN THEIR REPORT --
TO SOME OF THE PLACES WHERE THE
LAW -- THIS
STILL LEAVES ITSELF OPEN --
FOR DESIRE FOR CHANGE.
INTERPRETATION.
YES SIR.
THANK YOU.
I HAD A QUESTION OUTRAGE LOSING
ALL MY COLLEAGUES AS WELL SO I I
APPRECIATE YOUR FEEDBACK ON THAT
ONE THING YOU MENTIONED --
OF THE DIRECTOR IS WORKING WITH
THE HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION WHEN --
THE MOTHERS GIVING BIRTH THE
MAYBE CAN EXTEND THAT EVEN
FURTHER TALK OF THE DOCTORS ON
THE PRENATAL CHECKUPS ALL THAT
SO WELL IN ADVANCE.
I WOULDN'T WANT TO LEAVE --
OUR PARTNERS IN THE CMA OUT OF
IT I I WOULD ALSO SAY --
THE SEE AND A OKAY WELL --
WE'VE DONE SOME OUTRAGE FOR THEM
I'M VERY COMFORTABLE WITH BOTH
THAT -- THEY
OFTENTIMES FIND THEMSELVES AS
PROTECTION PRACTITIONERS.
OF WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT TRYING
TO MAKE THEIR WAY THROUGH THE
SYSTEM BUT I I AGREE WE WE CAN
STILL DO MORE.
AGAIN WE'VE DONE A LOT WITH THE
DOLLARS THAT WE HAVE WERE STILL
TRICKLING SOME OF THOSE --
DOLLARS AND LESSONS LEARNED.
OUT -- BUT
AGAIN WE'VE WE'VE EXPENDED ALL
THE FUNDS WE HAVE REPORT THAT'S
UP ON OUR WEBSITE IF ANYBODY.
WOULD LIKE TO SEE WHAT WE'VE
DONE AND WHAT THE NUMBERS WE
RECEIVE FROM THAT WE HAVE SEEN
UPTICK.
THE OVERALL UTILIZATION AS WELL
AS AS I SAID TO MISTER JONES
SAWYER IN PARTICULAR.
FOR A PATERNAL.
FATHERS USING THE SYSTEM BUT I I
COMPLETELY FOR THEIR VERY
DIFFERENT.
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA REALLY HAVE
KAISER --
THE SOCCER --
AND A FEW OTHER --
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IS A MUCH DIFFERENT
STORY BUT WHEN IT COMES TO THE
DIFFERENCE OF PEOPLE GIVING CARE
DOWN THE WHAT THE STEP WILL BE A
TEAM EFFORT I I THINK --
WITH ALL INVOLVES APPRECIATE
THAT AND THEN ONE QUESTION
ALEJO'S OFFICE REGARDING BECAUSE
I THINK IT'S PASSING IN THE HOLD
THE THE THE CONCEPTUAL PROPOSALS
OF THE SHARABLE ON TRANSFERABLE --
LEAVE OF A TEAM THE PARTNER'S
WHAT HAVE YOU --
OR EVEN SINGLE PARENTS TOOK
DOESN'T CLOSE RELATIVES OF THE
AYE IN CONCEPT A GREAT HOW THAT
ACTUALLY WORK TECHNICALLY.
THOUGH IN TERMS OF THE THE
DISABILITY INSURANCE PROGRAM OR
IS THAT SOMETHING WE HAD THAT WE
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT.
IT MAY BE THE CASE THAT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION SOME IN A BETTER
POSITION TO SPEAK TO THIS BUT IN
IN OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH WITH.
THE DEPARTMENT WITH THE PART OF
FINANCE AND WITH OTHERS ONE OF
THE KEY CONCERNS THAT THAT CAME
OUT VERY EARLY ON WAS THAT THESE
MORE.
I'LL CALL THEM UNIQUE POLICY
OPTIONS TRANSFER ABILITY
FLEXIBILITY.
WOULD LIKELY REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT
TIME FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO BUILD
NEW TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS TO DO
THESE AND THAT'S BECAUSE THE
GOVERNOR HAS AS IN A WAY RE
FRAMED.
HOW WE THINK ABOUT PAID FAMILY
LEAVE HE'S FRAMED IT AS --
SIX MONTHS OF LEAVE. FOR THE
CHILD.
BUT HISTORICALLY THE STATE HAS
OPERATED A PROGRAM AND HENCE
TECHNOLOGY AROUND OPERATING A
PROGRAM THAT IS SIX WEEKS OF
LEAVE. FOR AN EMPLOYEE --
AND THAT FOR INSTANCE.
IT'S NOT CLEAR WE WERE UNABLE TO
IDENTIFY.
SUS LINKING UP A PARTICULAR
MOTHER AND A PARTICULAR FATHER
OF THE SAME CHILD WHO WILL TAKE
LEAVE AT THE SAME TIME WE WE
DON'T TRACK THE THAT INFORMATION
ON THING SOME OF THESE MORE
UNIQUE.
OPTIONS THE ONLY THING I WOULD
FLAT WOULD REQUIRE SOME
SIGNIFICANT TECHNOLOGY CHANGES
WERE RE THINKING ABOUT THE
PROGRAM I THINK THE FALLS.
REALLY CLOSELY IN LINE WITH.
WHAT WE WOULD ENCOURAGE
LEGISLATURE JUST THINK ABOUT
THESE OPTIONS THERE ARE TRADE
OFFS MAYBE IT TAKES LONGER BUT
IF IT'S SOMETHING THE
LEGISLATURES TO INTEREST IN
DOING AND?
IT'S OBVIOUSLY A APPOINT START
THE CONVERSATION AND I THINK YOU
PUT IT VERY WELL AND I
ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S REFRAMING OF THIS
AROUND THE CHILD AND WHETHER
IT'S A PARENT.
OR A CLOSE RELATIVE ALIGNED
OPTION FOR THAT CHILD DURING A
LONGER DURATION OF TIME TO HAVE
THAT SUPPORT AND THE LOVE --
IS IS REALLY WHAT IT'S ABOUT
THAT I THINK THAT --
I APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR --
KIND OF A HAVING ALL OF US LOOK
AT IT DIFFERENTLY I DON'T NOTICE
ANY THOUGHTS OF MINISTRATION
THAT.
BUT WE'RE EXCITED TO SEE WHAT
GOVERNOR DO SOME HAS NEXT.
I GRANTED I THOUGHT.
WELL OF ANY OTHER QUESTIONS WITH
LOTS.
THANK YOU ALL SO VERY MUCH.
UP NEXT WE WILL HAVE --
THE PANEL.
ON THE ISSUES CONSIDER IN
EXPANDING PAID FAMILY LEAVE
WE'VE ALREADY KIND OF TOUCHED ON
THEM.
A LITTLE BIT --
AND WILL HAVE --
COMING UP.
DOCTOR CURTIS CHAN.
THE SAM DEPARTMENT.
OF PUBLIC HEALTH [inaudible]
JENNA GEHRY.
THE CALIFORNIA WORKING FAMILY
COALITION AND LEGAL AID.
THAT CALIFORNIA WORK AND FAMILY
COALITION.
I LEGAL IN A WORK.
AND AMID STAGGER WITH COFFEE
LIMóN FEDERATION I THINK I KIND
OF GOT ALL RIGHT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT --
DOCTOR CHEN.
SO THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBERS.
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
INTERESTS OF THIS REPEAT.
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT ISSUE HI MY
NAME IS CURTIS CHEN FOR THE PAST
TWENTY YEARS TAKING CARE OF
FAMILIES PRIMARILY IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND THE BAY AREA.
I ALSO SERVED AS DEPUTY HEALTH
OFFICER FOR THE SAN FRANCISCO
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
ALSO MEDICAL DIRECTOR MATERNAL
CHILD ADOLESCENT HEALTH --
IN ALL THESE HATS I WHERE I
BELONG TO SEVERAL HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS AND SEVERAL STATE
Y. CHILDREN'S ORGANIZATIONS.
AND MY TWENTY YEARS I HAVE NEVER
SEEN SO MANY STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATIONS COME TOGETHER FOR
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE.
SO THEY'VE ALL COME TOGETHER FOR
THIS CONCEPT IN CENTRAL COMMON
AGENDA CALLED EQUAL RIGHTS FOR
PARENTAL LEAVE.
BECAUSE OF THIS IMPACT ON CHILD
DEVELOPMENT AND THE OVERALL
HEALTH OF FAMILIES OVER THE LIFE
COURSE.
SO AT THE LEGISLATIVE.
ANALYST'S HAVE EXPLAINED THERE
ARE HUNDREDS OF ARTICLES AND
THIS IS ACTUALLY ONE OF THE MOST
WIDELY ESTABLISHED.
HEALTH BENEFITS OF ANY SINGLE
PUBLIC POLICY SO ALTHOUGH
THERE'S RELATIVE TO SOME MEDICAL
LITERATURE RELATIVE TO FOR
EXAMPLE CANCER THERAPEUTICS.
THERE'S SME LACK OF CLARITY ON
THE ACTUAL IMPACT A RELATIVE TO
OTHER SOCIAL ECONOMIC POLICIES
THE HIT THE HEALTH IMPACT OF
THIS IS EXTREMELY STRONG.
THIS IS WHY SO MANY HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS ARE STRONGLY IN
FAVOR OF THIS.
SO IN ADDITION TO THE ANALYSIS
FROM THE FROM THE LEGISLATURE
FROM ALEJO.
I JUST PUT IT INTO FIVE OVERALL
OVER ARCHING FRAMEWORKS THAT
PUBLIC HEALTH PRIORITIES.
IN CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN
EMPHASIZING FOR THE LAST DECADE.
SO THERE'S FIVE OF THEM SO ONE
OF THEM IS THAT A P. PRIME TO
LEAVE REDUCES TOXIC STRESS.
PARTICULARLY FOR LOW WAGE
FAMILIES --
AND THIS IS EVIDENT IN --
THAT SHOWS WHEN WE PASSED THE
PAID FAMILY LEAVE POLICY THERE
WAS THE ACTUAL DROP.
IN INCIDENTS OF HEAD TRAUMA DUE
TO ABUSE.
THIS IS AN EVIDENCE THIS IS
EVIDENCE OF ACTUALLY REDUCING
TOP EXPRESS AN ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES ACES ON CHILDREN.
THERE'S NO OTHER PUBLIC POLICY
THE HAS THAT TYPE OF REACH
NUMBER TWO MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH.
THIS.
PAY PARENTAL LEAVE ACTUALLY
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVES THE
SYMPTOMS OF POST PARTUM
DEPRESSION I HAVE AND ALSO
PRENATAL DEPRESSION AS WELL.
AND WE SEE THAT THERE SEVERAL
FOLDS INCREASED IN POST PARTUM
DEPRESSION MOST LOW WAGE EARNERS
PURSES HIGH WAGE EARNERS.
THE FIFTY THIRD ISSUE IN THE
LAST TEN YEARS WE REALIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF EARLY CHILDHOOD
BRAIN DEVELOPMENT.
THE FIRST TWELVE WEEKS THE FIRST
SIX MONTHS THEN EVEN EXTENDING
TO THE FIRST NINE MONTHS ARE
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL.
FOR EARLY BRAIN DEVELOPMENT
COGNITIVE DEVELOPMENT SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND THIS
LEADS TO A LIFE COURSE OF
LEARNING IN KINDERGARTEN
READINESS.
THE FOURTH ISSUE IS LIFE COURSE
THEORY.
SO THERE'S THREE COMPONENTS OF
LIFE COURSE THEORY IN WHICH PAID
PARENTAL LEAVE.
PARTICULARLY --
STRENGTHENS THE FIRST ASPECT IS
REACH.
THERE'S NO OTHER POLICY IN WHICH
EVERY HUMAN BORN IN CALIFORNIA
WILL BE REACHED EVERY BABY IN
EVERY SET OF PARENTS.
THE SECOND IS THERE IS A
CRITICAL WINDOW OF VULNERABILITY.
OBVIOUSLY FOR A NEWBORN INFANTS
UP TO SIX TO NINE MONTHS BUT
ALSO THIS IS THE PERIOD OF
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE
PHYSIOLOGICALLY FOR THE WOMAN
AND ALSO THIS IS THE GREATEST --
VULNERABILITY IN POST PARTUM
DEPRESSION AND MENTAL HEALTH --
ISSUES.
AND THE THIRD ASPECT IS THAT
FROM A LIFE COURSE PERSPECTIVE.
SCIENCE HELPS US UNDERSTAND THE
INTERVIEW INTERVENING AT THIS
EARLY STAGE FOR BOTH BABIES AND
MOTHERS AND FATHERS.
IS GOING TO LEAD TO A TRAJECTORY
THAT LASTS AN ENTIRE LIFETIME
PARTICULARLY IF THIS IS A POLICY
THAT AFFECTS EVERYBODY AND EVERY
COMMUNITY.
THE FIFTH AND FINAL --
HEALTH PRIORITY IN CALIFORNIA IS
THAT THIS ADDRESSES RACIAL
INEQUITIES AND RACISM.
SO CURRENTLY IN THE UNITED
STATES THE UTILIZATION OF
PARENTAL LEAVE POLICY IS AN
EQUALLY DISTRIBUTED BY WAGE
LEVEL.
AND REYES WHICH AS YOU ALL KNOW
IS LARGELY DETERMINED BY THE
AVAILABILITY OF WAGE REPLACEMENT
IN UNITED STATES.
WHEREAS WE RECOGNIZE OUR MANY
LONG STANDING HISTORICAL AND
STRUCTURAL REASONS FOR THESE
INEQUITIES.
IT'S REALLY A QUESTION FOR ALL
OF US AS A STATE IS HOW DO WE
NOW INSURER.
IN EQUAL STARTING LINE FOR ALL
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
SO -- IN THE
AGREEMENT WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYSIS --
ABOUT THE OVERALL HEALTH IMPACT --
MEDICAL HEALTH ORGANIZATIONS IN
THAT'S WIDENING IN THE UNITED
STATES BECAUSE OF THE DIFFERENCE
IN UPTAKE OF A PARENTAL LEAVE.
FOR EXAMPLE THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF OBSTETRICIANS AND
GYNECOLOGISTS WHO SEE.
PRETTY MUCH NEARLY A 100% OF ALL
WOMEN IN PRENATAL CARE.
EMPHASIZE A POLICY STATEMENT. TO
EMPHASIZE 1100% PAID PARENTAL
LEAVE IS.
THE POLICY THAT'S GOING TO MAKE
THE BIGGEST DIFFERENCE.
AND THE POLICY STATEMENT TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN HIGHLIGHTS THE
IMPACT OF PARENTAL LEAVE.
ON THE MANY WOMEN ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO WORK FOR SMALLER
COMPANIES HISPANICS LOWER WAGE
EARNERS AND THOSE WITH LESS THAN
A COLLEGE EDUCATION.
THEY'VE RECOGNIZE HAVING LESS
ACCESS TO PAID LEAVE.
THERE ARE SOME ISSUES IN WHICH
THOSE.
COMMUNITIES A MIGHT MAKE
POSSIBLY A LITTLE BIT OF SENSE
FOR THEM TO HAVE AN EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY.
BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR A BABY.
AT SIX TEN TWELVE WEEKS OLD TO
BE WITH HER.
MOTHER OR THEIR FATHER THIS IS
THE MOST BASIC OF HUMAN
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS.
FURTHERMORE THE MERIT ECONOMY A
PEDIATRICS WHICH WHICH ARE
SUGGESTED PORTRAITS OF OUTREACH
NOT IN PREMIER KERR BUT ALSO IN
PEDIATRIC CARE.
FURTHER EMPHASIZE THE ISSUE OF
EQUITY AND PAID LEAVE SO THIS IS
THE PRESIDENT OF AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS.
SAID THE MOST PARENTS CANNOT OF
OTHER CHILDREN.
IT'S THE CHILDREN WHO SUFFER THE
MOST.
ALL PARENTS SHOULD BE ABLE TO
BOND WITH AND CARE FOR THEIR
YOUNG CHILDREN.
DURING THE FIRST CRITICAL MONTHS
OF LIFE.
SO I APPRECIATE THE DILEMMAS
THAT THE STATE HAS IN FRONT OF A
AS IN FRONT OF US THERE'S A LOT
AND FOR THE SPECIFIC ISSUE OF A
NUMBER OF WEEKS PERCENTAGE OF
WHAT WAIT REPLACEMENT --
PATERNITY LEAVE FORCES MATERNITY
LEAVE AND THE OUTREACH ISSUE
THOSE FOUR ISSUES I WOULD JUST
PUT ON THE LANDS OF RACIAL
EQUITY AND SOCIAL EQUITY.
SO THE FIRST THE FIRST ONE IS
THE DURATION.
SO WE APPRECIATE THERE'S A LOT
OF DISCUSSION OF TWELVE WEEKS
WHICH IS THREE MONTHS PLUS IF --
THE BABY HAS A A SECOND PARENT
THAT WOULD ADD UP TO SIX MONTHS.
IT WE SHOULD STILL BE CLEAR THAT
THE HEALTH COMMUNITY BELIEVES
THAT SIX MONTHS TO TWELVE MONTHS.
IS THE RIGHT TIME SO THAT IS
WHAT'S --
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA --
AND OUR COMMUNITIES ARE STILL
ASKING FOR SIX TO TWELVE MONTHS
SO I WE REALIZE THAT IT'S WE IN
THE HEALTH PROFESSION TO FINANCE
THAT.
BUT THAT'S ACTUALLY WHAT'S MOST
BENEFICIAL TO CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES.
SO FROM A PEDIATRICS PERSPECTIVE
IT FOR THINKING ABOUT MY THREE
KIDS SIX MONTHS IS THE TIME FOR
EXCLUSIVE BREASTFEEDING.
THE TIME THE WINDOW FOR POST
PARTUM DEPRESSION THE RISK
PERIOD FOR SUDDEN INFANT DEATH
SYNDROME OCCURS UNTIL NINE
MONTHS SO THOSE ARE THE
PARTICULAR REASONS HE SCRATCHED
OUT TO THE WHL --
EXPECTS US TO HAVE SPREAD TO
LEAVE UNTIL TWENTY SIX WEEKS SO --
THAT'S WHY THERE'S A THE WINDOW
THE TIME FRAME IS SIX TO TWELVE
MONTHS --
THE SECOND ISSUE IS WAIT
REPLACEMENT IS ACTUALLY A SOCIAL
CLASS EQUITY ISSUE.
AND THERE'S MANY FACTORS I WOULD
SAY SIX TO TEN FANTASTIC
PROFESSORS IN CALIFORNIA CORE
NATIONAL INTERNATIONAL LEADERS
IN THE HEALTH IMPACT OF P.
PARENTAL LEAVE. ONE OF THEM IS
AT STANFORD MY A RASS US LATER.
AND SHE A HIGHLIGHTED IN A TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN ARTICLE IN THE
JOURNAL HEALTH ECONOMICS THAT
FMO LA WAS ASSOCIATED WITH MINOR
IMPROVEMENTS AND BIRTH WEIGHT.
MP MATURITY WEIGHT AS WELL AS A
DECREASE IT INTO MORTALITY
MEASURE IN THE FIRST YEAR OF
LIFE.
THE ONLY AMONG COLLEGE EDUCATED
WHITE MOTHERS.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS THE UNITED
STATES WHEN WE EIGHT RESOURCES
ONLY FOR A PARTICULAR PRIVILEGED
POPULATION.
SO THE THIRD AND FINAL THE THIRD
AN ALMOST FINAL ISSUE IS THE
DISTRIBUTION DOUBLE OF LEAVE.
BY GENDER WHEN I'M REVIEWING
THESE ARTICLES OF THE
INTERESTING ASPECT AS I I
APPRECIATE THE LA ILLS --
ANALYSIS IS A WE'RE LOOKING AT
DIFFERENT COUNTRIES IN NORWAY
SWEDEN GERMANY AT EACH INTERVAL
INCREASE IN.
PATERNITY LEAVE OR AND SENATORS
AND PATERNITY LEAVE.
THERE'S A IMPORTANT ASPECTS ON
FAMILY DYNAMICS FATHER'S
RESPONSIBILITY --
TO CARE FOR THEIR CHILD IT TO BE
ENGAGE WITH A CHILD'S
DEVELOPMENT AS WELL AT THE
SOCIAL DYNAMICS BETWEEN.
THE TWO PARTNERS SO IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT FOR THERE
TO BE ADEQUATE INCENTIVES FOR
THE HIGHER WAGE EARNERS IN SOME
CASES THEY MAY BE THE FATHERS.
TO BE ALSO BE TAKING LEAVE AS
WELL.
AND THE FOURTH AND FINAL COMMENT
I HAVE IS REGARDING OUT REACH
PUBLIC HEALTH HOSPITAL'S
PEDIATRICIANS --
OBGYN ENDS HAVE ALL STOOD FIRM
AND ARE ALL ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT
PARTICIPATING THERE ARE MANY
CREATIVE WAYS IN WHICH OUT WHICH
CAN BE DONE THROUGH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS WORKING
CLOSELY WITH HEALTH PROFESSIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS.
AND HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS --
WE THINK THAT OUTREACH IS
IMPORTANT METHOD TO ENSURE THAT
ALL FAMILIES UNDERSTAND THE
COMPLEXITIES.
THE AVAILABILITY OF A PARENTAL
LEAVE AND OVERALL PROCESS OF
ACTUALLY.
APPLYING AND RECEIVING THOSE
BENEFITS.
SO -- IS SO
IN SUMMARY I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME YOUR INTERESTS --
THIS IS THAT --
FINAL FRONTIER THIS IS THE FINAL
FRONTIER WHICH WERE WAY BEHIND.
IN TERMS OF SOCIAL POLICIES ALL
INDUSTRIALIZED COUNTRIES AND
THIS UNFORTUNATELY HAS THE
BIGGEST IMPACT FROM A LIFE
COURSE PERSPECTIVE ON CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES.
SO WE LOOK AT IT WE IN THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU IN THIS
UPCOMING YEAR TO ENSURE THERE'S
A POLICY.
THAT CARES FOR ALL CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CAN.
I JUST HAD ONE QUICK QUESTION I
KNOW WE'VE GOT OTHER PRESENTERS
BUT I'D ASK A QUESTION TO THE LA --
BEFORE ABOUT WHETHER YOU COULD
PROJECT ANYTHING ABOUT --
THE IMPACTS ON HEALTH CARE COSTS
OF INVESTING NOW.
AS WE'RE TRYING TO DECIDE IF YOU
WANT TO SPEND ANOTHER BILLION
DOLLARS AND PAID FAMILY LEAVE
AGAIN WE ALL INTUITIVELY BELIEVE
THAT THAT WILL SAVE.
LOTS OF DOLLARS IN THE FUTURE
AND YOU SPECIFIC HEALTH BENEFITS
THAT COME OUT THAT WE KNOW IF
YOU COMPARE COHORT OF FOLKS.
WHO HAVE PAID FAMILY LEAVE
VERSUS FAMILIES THAT DON'T WHAT
THE LONGER TERM HEALTH IMPACTS
ARE?
IS THERE ENOUGH IN THE
LITERATURE TO THINK TO ANALYZE
WHAT THE INVESTMENTS.
LEADS TO AS FAR AS LONGER TERM
HEALTH SAVINGS YEAH I I AGREE
WITH THE ANSWERS THAT ON THERE'S
HUNDREDS OF STUDIES --
AND THERE'S HUNDREDS OF
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THAT BY I WAS
NOT ABLE TO FIND A SINGLE
DOCUMENT I THINK.
THAT'S A GOOD I THINK THERE'S
ENOUGH THERE TO TH. FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND ITS THE
LEADERS DURING THIS YEAR OF A
WORK GROUP TO ACTUALLY COME UP
WITH SOME ESTIMATE SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING ABOUT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU --
WITH.
A GEHRY.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME SO I'M GONNA GARY AND
I'M A SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY WITH
LEGAL AID AT WORK --
AND I MEAN THEIR WORK AND FAMILY
PROGRAM AND SO SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY THREE THE WORK AND FAMILY
PROGRAM HAS BEEN ADVOCATING FOR
THE RIGHTS OFLOW INCOME WORKERS
PARTICULARLY.
PREGNANT AND YOU PARENTS AND
CAREGIVERS MAKING SURE THEY HAVE
JOB PROTECT THE TIME OFF ARE
GETTING PAID AND HAVE REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATIONS --
IN ADDITION TO REPRESENTING
CLIENTS IN LITIGATION WE ALSO DO
A LOT OF COMMUNITY OUTREACH AND
EDUCATION AND WE MAN A WORKING
FAMILY HELP LINE THAT'S
AVAILABLE STATEWIDE.
SO EACH YEAR WE HEAR FROM
FIFTEEN HUNDRED TO TWO THOUSAND
WORKERS WHO ARE STRUGGLING WITH
FAMILY RELATED ISSUES AT WORK --
THE STORIES OF OUR CALLERS AND
OUR CLIENTS HAVE REALLY GIVEN US
INSIGHT INTO THE CURRENT GAPS IN
THE LAW.
AND INSPIRED US TO PUSH FOR
CHANGES --
WE ARE ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA WHERE SHIN.
AND SO WITH OUR PARTNERS WE
REALLY FOCUS ON HOW OUR LOW
INCOME WORKERS BEING LEFT BEHIND
IN OUR CURRENT SYSTEM.
SO TODAY I JUST WANNA HIGHLIGHT
THREE SPECIFIC BARRIERS THAT WE
SEE COME UP OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
WHICH WE HOPE WILL BE KEPT IN
MIND WE'RE CONSIDERING AN
EXPANSION OF THE CURRENT PROGRAM
TO REALLY MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S
NOT UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
THAT WOULD INCREASE THAN
EQUITIES WE SEE IN THE PROGRAM.
SO THE FIRST ONE SEVEN
CALIFORNIA ARE JOB PROTECTION IN
INCOME REPLACEMENT LAWS ARE NOT
WELL LINE.
WHICH MEANS MANY PEOPLE ARE
DENIED ACCESS THE FAMILY LEAVE
OR HAVE TO CUT THEIR LEAVE SHORT.
SEVEN AS WE'VE ALREADY HEARD
TODAY THE CALIFORNIA'S PAID
FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM VIRTUALLY
COVERS ALL PRIVATE EMPLOYEES IN
THE STATE AND ALLOWS AN ACCESS
SIX WEEKS.
OF INCOME REPLACEMENT WHILE
THEY'RE CARING FOR A NEW CHILD
OR CARING FOR A SERIOUSLY ILL
FAMILY MEMBER.
THE PROBLEM IS THE ENTIRELY
EMPLOYEE FUNDED PROGRAM ONLY
PROVIDES MONETARY BENEFITS IT
DOES NOT PROVIDE ANY SORT OF JOB
PROTECTION.
THIS MEANS YOU CAN BE FIRED
LEGALLY FOR ACCESSING BENEFITS
YOU PAY.
FOR THAT'S BECAUSE OUR JOB
PROTECTION LAWS THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY RIGHTS ACT --
A LOT THE WHICH ALLOWS WORKERS
TO TAKE UP TO TWELVE WEEKS OF
JOB PROTECTED BUT UNPAID TIME
OFF FOR THEIR OWN SERIOUS HEALTH
CONDITION. TO CARE FOR A FAMILY
MEMBER THE SERIOUS HEALTH
CONDITION OR TO BOND WITH A NEW
CHILD ONLY APPLIES TO EMPLOYEES
WHO WORK AT COMPANIES WITH FIFTY
OR MORE EMPLOYEES WITHIN A
SEVENTY FIVE MILE RADIUS.
HAD TO HAVE BEEN THERE FOR A
YEAR AND YOU HAD TO WORK A TOTAL
OF ONE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY HOURS IN THE YEAR PRIOR TO
YOUR LEAVE.
NOTHING SAYS SENATOR JACKSON --
SB ANY EIGHTEEN DID EXPAND THIS
JOB PROTECTION FOR NEW PARENTS
DOWN TO A TWENTY EMPLOYEE
THRESHOLDS.
HOWEVER THIS STILL LEAVES
WORKERS WHO WORK FOR SMALLER
COMPANIES BELOW TWENTY OR WHO
WORK PART TIME OR WHO HAVEN'T
BEEN THERE YEAR.
VERY VULNERABLE WHEN A NEW TRIAL
COMES INTO THEIR LIFE OR FAMILY
MEMBER GETS STALE THEY HAVE NO
RIGHT TO TAKE ANY TIME OFF OF
WORK.
UNFORTUNATELY LOW WAGE WORKERS
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY LESS
LIKELY TO BE COVERED BY THESE
JOB PROTECTIONS.
AND WE'VE HEARD FROM COUNTLESS
COLOR IS TO HEAR ABOUT PAID
FAMILY LEAVE WHICH IN ITSELF IS
A GREAT THING THAT THEY'VE HEARD
OF IT.
AND THEY GO TO TELL THEIR
EMPLOYER THEY WANT TO TAKE THESE
BENEFITS AND THEY'RE SHOCKED TO
FIND OUT THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
THE RIGHT TO DO SO.
A TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN SURVEY
FOUND THAT ALMOST TWO OUT OF
FIVE EMPLOYEES WERE WHO ARE
ELDERLY USED VIA FILE.
CHOSE NOT TO APPLY FOR BECAUSE
THEY FEARED LOSING THEIR JOB OR
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES.
SO ANOTHER AREA IN WHICH HE IS
THE DURATION A EVER ARE JOB
PROTECTION ARE PAID ON MATCH UP
IS THE DURATION OF LEAVE LIKE I
SAID OUR JOB PROTECTION LAWS.
ALLOW FOR TWELVE WEEKS OF TIME
OFF WATER PAID FAMILY LEAVE
PROGRAM OFF ONLY AFTER SIX WEEKS
OF BENEFITS.
NOW FOR LOW WAGE WORKERS WERE
LESS LIKELY TO HAVE ACCESS TO
OTHER FORMS OF PAID LEAVE THIS
MEANS THEY HAVE TO CUT THEIR
LEAVE SHORT BECAUSE I CAN'T
AFFORD IT --
IT'S ALSO VERY DIFFICULT IF NOT
IMPOSSIBLE TO FIND CHILDCARE FOR
A SIX WEEK HERE OLD.
AND THEREFORE --
LOW WAGE WORKERS PARTICULARLY A
I PARTICULARLY WOMEN WE SEE OUR
FAIR MARKET THE JOB MARKET --
YOU REVERSE LEE LIMóN THEIR
FUTURE EARNING CAPACITY AND
CAREER PATH.
LASTLY IF THE DEFINITION OF
FAMILY MEMBERS WITHIN OUR JOB
PROTECTION LAWS AND OUR WAITER
PLACEMENT PROGRAM OR DIFFERENT
SO THE PAID FAMILY LEAVE LAW NOW
COVERS YOUR ABILITY TO CARE FOR
CIVILIANS GRANDPARENTS
GRANDCHILDREN PARENTS.
PARENTS ALLIES --
IN ADDITION TO PARENTS SPOUSES
REGISTERED DOMESTIC PARTNERS AND
CHILDREN OF ALL AGES --
WHICH IS GREAT AND WE LOVE THAT
EXPANSIVE DEFINITION BUT
UNFORTUNATELY TO GET JOB
PROTECTION YOU ONLY HAVE THE
RIGHT TO TAKE JOB PROTECTED
LEAVE IF IT'S YOUR PARENT.
AIR SPELLS OR YOUR MINOR CHILD --
AND SO MANY PEOPLE WHO HAVE A
FAMILY MEMBER WHO FALLS ILL
AGAIN CAN GET THESE BENEFITS BUT
IF YOU DON'T HAVE A JOB TO GO.
TO TERRON THAT'S EXTREMELY
PROBLEMATIC.
AND PARTICULARLY BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES DO NOT LOOK
THE SAME AS THEY DID DECADES AGO.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN A RECORD SIXTY
FOUR MILLION PEOPLE OR 20% OF
THE US POPULATION LIVED WITH
MULTIPLE GENERATIONS UNDER ONE
ROOF AND CALIFORNIA HAS THE
SECOND HIGHEST PERCENTAGE OF
MULTI GENERATIONAL FAMILIES IN
THE US.
ANOTHER MAJOR BEARISH OUR
CLIENTS ACCESSING THE PAID
FAMILY PROGRAM WHICH HAS BEEN
TOUCHED UPON IS THE CURRENT WAGE
REPLACEMENT RATE.
SO IF YOU'RE MAKING MINIMUM WAGE
AND PARTIAL INCOME WON'T ALLOW
YOU TO PAY THE RENT OR EXPENSES
ESPECIALLY WITH A NEW BABY IS
JOINING THE HOUSEHOLD.
ALTHOUGH AB NINE OH EIGHT THE
BILL THAT RAISE THE WAGE
REPLACEMENT RATE TO SIXTY OR 70%
WAS A GREAT FIRST THAT.
IT'S SIMPLY JUST NOT ENOUGH FOR
MANY WORKERS SO TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THANKS TO CENTER WIENER IS
LEADERSHIP THE SAN FRANCISCO
PASSED THE FIRST OF ITS KIND
PAID PARENTAL LEAVE ORDINANCE.
THAT ACTUALLY REQUIRES EMPLOYERS
AND SAN FRANCISCO TO TOP UP THE
STATE BENEFITS TO WORKERS IN SAN
FRANCISCO GET A 100% DURING
THOSE SIX WEEKS --
FORTUNATELY THERE'S BEEN A GREAT
SOME REALLY PROMISING RESULTS
THAT SHOW WHAT CAN HAPPEN WHEN
YOU GET TO FULL PAY.
SO EARLY ADMINISTRATIVE DATA
INDICATES A 6% INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF WOMEN TAKING MONEY
LEAVE IN THE FIRST HALF OF THE
YEAR THE ORGANS WHEN THE FACT
FIRST OF THE FIRST.
HALF OF THE YEAR AND THE YEAR
PRIOR AND THIS IS A COMPARED TO
VIRTUALLY NO CHANGE IN THE REST
OF THE STATE.
AND THEN MORE INTERESTINGLY
THERE WAS A 28% INCREASE IN MEN
TAKING BONNIE LEAVE AND SAN
FRANCISCO AS COMPARED TO A THREE
POINT 9% INCREASE OVER ALL --
IN ANOTHER INTERESTING.
FINDING FROM THE STUDY IS THAT
78% OF EMPLOYERS REPORTED BE IN
SUPPORT OF OUR VERY SUPPORT OF
OTHER PAID PARENTAL LEAVE
ORDINANCE WITH ONLY 6% OPPOSE.
AND THE VAST MAJORITY OF
EMPLOYERS REPORTED THAT THEIR
SUPPORT OF THE ORDINANCE BUT
EITHER IMPROVE OR NOT CHANGE IF
IT WERE FUNDED THROUGH A PAYROLL
TAX.
SOMETHING WE BELIEVE WE SHOULD
BE CONSIDERED WHEN EXPLORING
WAYS TO FUND AN EXPANSION OF THE
PROGRAM AND HOW WE PAY FOR IT.
SO THE FINAL BARRIER WHICH I
THINK WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT IS
SIMPLY THAT PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THIS PROGRAM AND THERE'S
WIDESPREAD CONFUSION BECAUSE AS
I JUST EXPLAINED.
OUR PAYS THE PAPER VERSION AND
THE JOB REDUCTION THEY DON'T
LINE UP AND THEY DON'T MAKE
SENSE.
SO EVEN THOUGH IT'S BEEN IN
EFFECT FOR OVER A DECADE.
WE NOW FOR MY TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN FIELD POLL THAT ONLY
THIRTY PER 6% OF CALIFORNIA
VOTERS WHERE WHERE THE PROGRAM.
WHICH IT WAS A SIGNIFICANT
DECREASE FROM 43% HOME WHERE THE
PROGRAM IN TWENTY ELEVEN IT'S
ACTUALLY WHERE NESS HAD WENT
DOWN -- IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN TO CALIFORNIA
WORKING FAMILY COALITION AND
SUCCESSFULLY ADVOCATED FOR
FUNDING IN THE BUDGET FOR EDT
FROM DOCTOR OUTRAGE ON PFL.
WHICH WE HIRED --
EDT TALK A BIT ABOUT WHICH WAS
GREAT CAN ONLY PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON INCOME
REPLACEMENT IS A DEPARTMENT OF
FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING THAT
ENFORCES ARE JOB PROTECTION LAWS
AND THEREFORE CAN ONLY TALK
ABOUT JOB PROTECTION.
AND THERE'S SIMPLY NO
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH FOR
SOMEONE TO ACTUALLY EDUCATE ON
THE FULL.
SCOPE OF WHAT IT MEANS TO TAKE
RENTAL LEAVE [inaudible]
AND IN ADDITION PEOPLE LACK
ACCESS BECAUSE OF LANGUAGE ARE
TECHNOLOGICAL BARRIERS ND NEED
ASSISTANCE IS NOT CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE FROM GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES. TO THE BIGGEST BEARS
WE SEE IS THE PAPER APPLICATION
WHICH MOST LOW INCOME WORKERS
USE IS NOT EVEN IN SPANISH IT IS
ONLY AVAILABLE IN ENGLISH.
AND AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT IS
A HUGE BARRIER.
SO JUST SIMPLY PUT OUR FAMILY
MEDICALLY LAST NOT KEPT PACE
WITH THE OF ALL THE NEED TO
WORKING FAMILIES WHEN A NEW
TRIAL COMES IN THE HOME OR
FAMILY MEMBER IS ILL.
ACCESS LEAVE AS BOTH PAID AND
JOB PROTECTED IS TRULY ESSENTIAL.
WHAT CALIFORNIA'S LED THE WAY
AND FAMILY'S SUPPORT OF
WORKPLACE POLICIES THERE'S MORE
THAT WE CAN AND SHOULD DO?
I'M SURE THAT WORKERS CAN TAKE
LEAVE WITHOUT RISKING THEIR JOBS
EDUCATE WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS
ABOUT THE RIGHTS AND OBLIGATIONS.
EXPAND FAMILY LEAVE RIGHT TO
TRULY MEET THE NEEDS OF WORKING
FAMILIES THANK YOU.
HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO THANK
YOU LESTER WORKS I GET JUST A
QUICK COMMENT A QUESTION FOR MS
CAREY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS --
YOU ALSO TOUCH ON SOMETHING --
I THINK IS WORTH PUTTING A FINER
POINT TO THAT NO WE DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO THESE CHILD AT TO THE
YOU KNOW --
IT PAID FAMILY LEAVE AND WE ALSO
DON'T HAVE AT AND EXACERBATES
THE GENDER PAY GAP.
SAID AS BIGGER SOCIETAL ISSUES
FOR US SO I THINK WE ALSO NEED
TO THINK ABOUT THE CONTEXT AT
HOME PORT THESE PROGRAMS ARE FOR
THE WHOLE FAMILY --
BUT ONCE SPECIFIC QUESTION FOR
YOU THE THE WORKERS THAT ARE
EXCLUDED FROM --
ACCESS -- TO
PAID LEAVE DO YOU HAVE A NUMBER
OF ESTIMATE HOW MANY WORKERS
USING THAT IS IN CALIFORNIA.
EITHER JOB PROTECTION OF THE
PAID LEAVE.
THE FORTUNE --
WILL VIRTUALLY ALL EMPLOYEES PAY
INTO IT IT'S ALL PRIVATE
EMPLOYEES --
BUT I YOU KNOW RIGHT NOW I THINK
THE LAST IT IS LIKE I SAW IS
THAT LOW INCOME WORKERS MADE UP
40% OF THE EMPLOYEES PAIN INTO
IT BUT ONLY 24% OF THE CLAIMANTS
RECEIVING THE BENEFITS OKAY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU --
AND THEN MISDIAGNOSIS.
CLOSE TO A QUICK FOLLOW AT TIMES
BECAUSE YOU CUT YOURSELF --
BUT I JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT OF COURSE NOT ALL.
OF PUBLIC SECTOR WORKERS ARE
INVOLVED IN OUR PAID LEAVE
PROGRAM IN SOUTH OF ACT ALL THAT
I JUST PRESENTED ON TEACHERS SO.
WHEN A HIGHLIGHT THAT SOMEHOW
WE'VE --
EXCLUDED PUBLIC EMPLOYEES OUT OF
THE PROGRAM AND AND THAT HAS A
SUBSTANTIAL EFFECT I THINK IT'S
YEAH ABSOLUTELY.
YEAH.
THANK YOU HAVE A STRIKE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MITCH STAGGER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION --
WE APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COME IN HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY
ABOUT THIS PROGRAM IT'S ONE
THAT'S VERY NEAR AND DEAR TO OUR
HEARTS WE WERE PROUD TO SPONSOR
THE BILL THAT CREATED THE
PROGRAM BACK IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWO AND IT'S REALLY
BECOME ONE WHERE WE WHERE OF THE
PROGRAM IN THE COULD TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF IT.
THE BENEFITS ARE SO CLEAR AND
OBVIOUS THAT IT'S IT'S KIND OF
HARD TO REMEMBER WHAT IT WAS
LIKE BEFORE WE HAD THAT THAT.
IT USED TO REALLY BE JUST KIND
OF THE NORM THAT PARENTS.
DIDN'T HAVE ACCESS TO TIME TO
BOND WITH THEIR KIDS OR TIME.
TO CARE FOR A SICK LOVE ONE AND
THAT THE PROGRAM HAS BEEN SO
SUCCESSFUL PEOPLE HAVE TAKEN
SUCH STRONG ADVANTAGE OF IT THAT.
IT REALLY IS JUST PART OF OUR
CULTURE DIRECTOR HAVING TALKED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
DIFFICULTIES INVOLVED IN
CHANGING CULTURE WELL THAT'S
TRUE.
WE DO THINK THAT THIS REALLY
STANDS OUT AS A SHINING EXAMPLE
PUBLIC POLICY THAT HAS DONE THAT
THAT HAS CHANGED THE CULTURE AND
HAS PLAYED A VERY DECISIVE ROLE
IN.
NOT ONLY CHANGING INDIVIDUAL
WORKERS LIVES BUT ALSO CHANGING
THE WAY THAT WE AS A STATE LOOK
AT THE ISSUE OF BONDING WITH
THEIR CHILDREN AND TAKING CARE
OF LOVED ONES AND SO.
WE'RE WERE HUGE SUPPORTERS OF
THE PROGRAM AND VERY MUCH WANT
TO PROTECT IT AND EXPAND --
IT'S PRETTY CLEAR THAT SIX WEEKS
IS OFTEN NOT ENOUGH THE THE
SCIENCE IS CLEAR AND THOSE OF US
WITH CHILDREN KNOW HOW HARD IT
WAS YOU KNOW IT'S SIX WEEKS TO
IMAGINE JUST WALKING AWAY AND
PUTTING IN A DAY CARE AT THAT IS
AT THAT AMOUNT OF TIME IS.
A VERY VERY HARD THING TO WRAP
YOUR HEAD SO --
IS SOMETHING THAT WE VERY MUCH
LIKE TO SEE HAPPEN IN TERMS OF
EXPANDING AND THE THE LENGTH OF
BENEFITS THE THE WAGE
REPLACEMENT WHATEVER WE DECIDE
MAKES THE MOST SENSE BUT IT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE SUPPORT.
AND WE HOPE THAT THIS RENEWED
FOCUS ON THE PROGRAM GIVES US A
CHANCE TO RESTORE WHAT WE THINK
IS A LONG OVERDUE CONVERSATION
ABOUT FINANCING.
WHERE -- IT
WAS MENTIONED BY THE PREVIOUS
PANEL THAT WE ARE REALLY KIND OF
AN OUT LIAR WHEN IT COMES TO THE
WAY THAT WE FINANCE OUR PROGRAM
IN THAT WORKERS PAY 41100% OF IT --
OF THE SEVEN STATES WELL SIX
STATES THE DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA
THAT DO HAVE PAID FAMILY LEAVE.
IT'S JUST CALIFORNIAN RHODE
ISLAND THAT ASK FOR WORKERS TO
PAY FOR THE ENTIRE PROGRAM.
AND I TRIED TO GO THROUGH THE
THE IOWA WEBSITE TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT LOOKS LIKE IN OTHER
COUNTRIES --
AND IT'S A IT'S KIND OF HARD TO
MAKE SENSE OUT OF SOME OF THE
INFORMATION THAT'S ON THERE BUT
IT'S VERY VERY HARD TO FIND A
COUNTRY THAT.
DOES THE SAME THING THE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
COUNTRIES EITHER HAVE EMPLOYERS
PAY FOR ALL OR SOME OF THE
PROGRAM.
AND SO WE REALLY DO KIND OF
STAND OUT AND THE FRUSTRATING
THING ABOUT THAT IS THAT THE
PROGRAM WAS ORIGINALLY THE BILL
THAT CREATED IT HAD SIX WEEKS
FOR WORKERS.
AND IN SIX WEEKS FUNDED BY A SIX
WEEKS FUNDED BY WORKERS IN SIX
WEEKS FUNDED BY EMPLOYERS SO.
IT WAS A SHARED COST BETWEEN
THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT YOU'VE
BENEFITS EVERYONE DIRECTLY
BENEFIT WORKERS IN TERMS OF TIME
WITH THEIR LOVED ONES IT ALSO
BENEFITS NOT JUST EMPLOYERS BUT
SOCIETY AT LARGE IN TERMS OF ALL
ALL THE BENEFITS THAT THAT WERE
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED AND SO.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE REALLY
SEE.
AS A PROGRAM THAT SHOULD BE A
SHARED INVESTMENT BY BOTH
WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS IN THAT WE
SHOULD ALL PRIORITIZE AND WERE
WE TO SET A PRECEDENT NOW WITH A
WE'RE HAVING THIS CONVERSATION
ABOUT SOME SORT OF MAJOR
EXPANSION.
TO JUST GO BACK TO WORKERS AND
TALK ABOUT.
RAISING THE THE EXISTING TAXES
ON WORKERS WE THINK WOULD BE.
FRANKLY PRETTY UNFAIR AND UNWISE
FOR A FEW DIFFERENT REASONS ONE
ISSUE IS THAT RIGHT NOW THE D.
I. FUND IS --
TO OVER A BILLION DOLLARS AS A
RESULT OF WHAT ARE CALLED
WORKERS COMPENSATION LEANS.
SO RIGHT NOW IF YOU'RE WORKER
YOU GET HURT ON THE JOB I AND
YOU GO TO YOUR EMPLOYER IF THE
EMPLOYER BELIEVES THAT THE
INJURY ISN'T WORK RELATED.
MOST OF THE TIME THOSE WORKERS
ARE FORCED TO GO INTO THE D. I.
FUND TO GET BY THEY DON'T GET
THE TEMPORARY DISABILITY
BENEFITS THAT THEY'RE ENTITLED
TO ONE OF THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM.
AND SO THEN THE CLAIM GOES
THROUGH THE SYSTEM IS FOUND THAT
IT WAS WORK RELATED.
THE IDEA IS THAT THE STATE THEN
GOES BACK AND GETS THAT MONEY
FROM EMPLOYERS INPUTS THAT BACK
INTO THE AYE FUND.UNFORTUNATELY THAT DOESN'T
ALWAYS HAPPEN AND SO NOW THERE'S
AN ESTIMATED ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS THAT THAT SHOULD
BE IN THERE.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT WORKERS
COMP FIFTEEN AND ALL INDICATIONS
ARE THAT THAT THE CLIENTS GOING
TO CONTINUE SO WE'VE GOT A
SITUATION WHERE.
WORKERS COMP COSTS ARE GOING
DOWN IN PART BECAUSE EMPLOYERS
AREN'T PAYING THE CLAIMS THAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED.
TO AND WORKERS ARE HAVING TO
ESSENTIALLY MAKE UP THE
DIFFERENCE OUT OF THEIR OWN
POCKETS AND SO.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE REALLY
THINK NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED.
THERE IS ALSO AN ISSUE WITH THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE SYSTEM
WHERE --
WHEN THE WHEN THE RECESSION
STARTED IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
AND THE STATE HAD TO START
BORROWING MONEY FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT?
THE THE LOANS GENERATE MASSIVE
AMOUNTS OF INTEREST HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
A YEAR THAT AT THE TIME THE
GENERAL FUND DIDN'T HAVE THE
MONEY FOR THE GENERAL FUND WAS
IN PRETTY BAD SHAPE.
AND SO THE MONEY WAS ESSENTIALLY
LOAN FROM THE D. I. FUNDS TO THE
U. I TRUST FUND TO COVER THAT
COST.
AND THE THE LOANS WERE NOT
ENTIRELY PAID BACK SO BY MY MATH
AT LEAST IT'S STILL OWED ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
SECOND LOAN.
AND THE THE DEEPER PROBLEM
THERE'S THERE'S A REAL
STRUCTURAL INSOLVENCY BUILT INTO
THE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
SYSTEM SO IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE THE U. I
TRUST FUND ENDED THE YEAR.
IN IN THE POSITIVE BALANCE FOR
THE FIRST TIME SINCE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT SO IT'S
ESSENTIALLY BEEN BANKRUPT FOR A
DECADE.
AND THE SECOND ANOTHER RECESSION
STARTS IT'S A PRETTY SAFE BET
THAT THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN AGAIN AND WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO GO FIND SOME OTHER
SOURCE TO COVER THE INTEREST ON
THE FEDERAL LOANS AND THAT MAYBE
THE P. I. FUND SO.
HERE WE'VE GOT A SITUATION UNDER
FUNDED STRUCTURALLY AS A MATTER
OF COURSE BY EMPLOYERS AND
WORKERS HAVE TO FUND THE
DIFFERENCE OUT OF THEIR OWN
POCKET SO.
IT'S IT IT'S FRUSTRATING FOR US
TO LOOK AT THESE TWO PROGRAMS
AND REALIZE THAT BECAUSE WE'VE
SET ASIDE THIS MONEY. TO TAKE
CARE OF OURSELVES WHEN TIMES ARE
TOUGH IT'S A THEN KIND OF USED.
TO BAIL OUT EMPLOYERS THAT DON'T
PAY LEGITIMATE WORKERS
COMPENSATION CLAIMS AND DEAL
WITH THE STRUCTURAL INSOLVENCY
THE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
SYSTEM.
SO IT'S WE BELIEVE UNFAIR TO
SOME DEGREE TO LOOK AT THAT
FUNDING LOOK AT US AS THE PLACE
TO MAKE UP THE DIFFERENCE IN
FUNDING THAT WOULD BE NECESSARY
FOR AN EXPANSION.
AND THIS IS ALL IN ADDITION TO
THE FACT THAT WORKER WAGES HAVE
ESSENTIALLY BEEN STAGNANT SINCE
THE MID SEVENTIES.
THAT UNLESS YOU'RE IN THE
NINETIETH WAGE PERCENTILE OR
ABOVE YOU REALLY HAVEN'T SEEN A
REYES AND FORTY OR FORTY FIVE
YEARS ON AVERAGE AND SO.
GOING TO THOSE WORKERS TO THAN
FROM THE INCREASE IN BENEFITS IS
JUST ONE MORE BURDEN THAT MOST
OF US REALLY JUST CAN'T AFFORD --
AND ALSO GETTING INTO THE ISSUE
OF SOLVENCY CONCERNS THERE'S
BEEN SOME DISCUSSION ABOUT
LOWERING THE SOLVENCY
REQUIREMENTS IN THE FUND TO HELP --
THE FUND A LITTLE BIT OF WHAT
THE EXPANSION MIGHT COST AGAIN
GIVEN THAT THE D. I. FUND IS
ALREADY OWED TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE TWENTY TWELVE
LOAN.
IT'S A LITTLE SCARY TO START
THINKING ABOUT WEAKENING THAT
SOLVENCY BECAUSE IT WE
ESSENTIALLY JUST KIND OF
PRETENDED THAT MONEY WAS THERE
AS WE WERE LOANING THE MONEY OUT.
AND THEY GOT THEIR SESSION
DIDN'T GET MUCH WORSE BUT HAD
THAT HAPPENED.
NO ONE REALLY KNOWS WHETHER OR
NOT THAT'S THE FUN TIMES SINCE
IT WAS.
AND SO THOSE SONGS HE
REQUIREMENTS THERE IN LAW --
WERE KIND OF CREATED THROUGH A
PAINFUL PROCESS OF TRIAL AND
ERROR IT WASN'T JUST SOMETHING
THAT THAT WAS CREATED IT WAS US
REALIZING THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE
ENOUGH MONEY IN THE FUND TO
COVER THESE BENEFITS AND SO WE
NEEDED TO KEEP MORE IN THERE.
AND SO WERE EXTREMELY CONCERNED
WITH ANYTHING THAT WOULD WEAKEN
THE SOLVENCY REQUIREMENTS --
AS WAS MENTIONED THERE IS ALSO
CONCERN WITH THE FACT THAT SO
MANY WORKERS DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO THE PROGRAM WHETHER IT'S
CLEARLY IN THE LOG SOMETHING
THAT DOESN'T PROTECT THEM IF
THEY DO HAVE FEWER THAN TWENTY
CO WORKERS.
AND THEY TRY TO TAKE THE LEAVE
AND AS WAS MENTIONED EMPLOYER
COMPLETELY FIRE THEM.
THE SAD REALITY IS THAT EVEN IF
YOU ARE PROTECTED EVEN IF YOU DO
HAVE AT LEAST TWENTY CO WORKERS
THAT.
THIS IS A LAW THAT STUFF TO
ENFORCE THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
WORKERS OUT THERE THAT ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE PROTECTED BUT
THEY'RE WELL AWARE OF THE FACT
THAT IF THEY TAKE THIS LEAVE
THEY MAY NOT GET CALLED BACK THE
THEY WILL CERTAINLY BE FIRED FOR
SOME OTHER.
REASON AND IT'S AN EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT THING TO PROVE THAT
AND SO IT'S GOOD THAT THE LAW IS
THERE BUT IT DEFINITELY DOESN'T
SOLVE THE PROBLEM THERE ARE MANY
THAT ON THAT WOULD BE PROTECTED
BY THAT.
AND ONE OTHER LAST ISSUE TO
RAISE IS THAT IF WE WERE TO
EXPAND THE PROGRAM IN A WAY THAT
JUST RAISE THE WAGE REPLACEMENT
BENEFITS.
THAT MANY EMPLOYERS OUT THERE
COORDINATE BENEFITS SO THE
PROGRAM GIVES YOU YOUR 6270% OF
YOUR WAGES AND THEN THE EMPLOYER
WILL PAY FOR THE ADDITIONAL
3240%.
AND SO WERE WE TO FUND THE X.
EMPLOYERS DO THAT THEN GET THE
ADDITIONAL MONEY AND BASICALLY
TURN AROUND AND GIVE IT TO THEIR
EMPLOYERS SO IN A SENSE IT'S
RAISING TAXES ON WORKERS TO THEN.
JUST TURN AROUND AND HANDED OVER
THE EMPLOYER AND SO THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WERE A LITTLE BIT
WORRIED ABOUT MAY CREATE SOME.
HEARTBURN AMONG THOSE WORKERS
THAT WOULD THEN SEE THAT PROCESS
HAPPEN --
BUT THOSE ARE JUST A GENERALLY
OUR MAIN PERSPECTIVES ON THE
SYSTEM AND JUST TO SUMMARIZE
AGAIN.
THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT WE VERY
VERY MUCH DO SUPPORT AND WOULD
LIKE TO SEE EXPANDED WE LOOK
VERY MUCH FORWARD TO BEING
INVOLVED IN THE TASK FORCE.
TO FIGURE OUT HOW THE EXPANSION
HAPPENS.
IN IMAGE MADE MENTION OF THEM
AND AND MISS KERRY MADE MENTION
OF THE KIND OF FEAR THAT WORKERS
HAVE. TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF OF OF
OF TAKING ANY FAMILY LEAVE --
BUT SHOULD BE XIN OF RETALIATION
AND MORE PRESUMING THAT YOU
AGREE THAT YOUR TELEVISION IS A
PROBLEM.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS THERE
ANYTHING THE LEGISLATURE CAN DO?
TO ENSURE THAT WICKS WORKERS
TAKE FAMILY LEAVE WITHOUT FEAR
OF ANY.
ADVERSE EMPLOYMENT ACTION.
IS ANYTHING MORE THAT WE CAN DO
DO YOU THINK.
WELL IT'S IT'S A PROBLEM WITHOUT
IT'S A VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD
PROBLEM WITHOUT A
STRAIGHTFORWARD SOLUTION WHERE
IT REALLY JUST COMES DOWN TO
ENFORCEMENT AND TYPICALLY.
THESE THINGS TAKE A VERY VERY
LONG TIME THAT'S PART OF THE
PROBLEM AND THAT'S A PRETTY.
PRETTY SIMPLE ONE TO DEAL WITH --
ANOTHER VERY IMPORTANT STEP A
STRONG UNION AND IF THEY DO HAVE
ACCESS TO A SPECIALLY --
JUST BECAUSE PROTECTIONS IN
THEIR CONTRACT THEN ONE THING
THEY CAN DO IS STAND UP FOR
THEIR RIGHTS AND EMPLOYER DOES
NOT HAVE THE RIGHT TO FIRE THEM
AND YOU'VE GOT A WHOLE
ADDITIONAL LAYER OF ENFORCEMENT
THERE WHERE.
THE UNION CAN FILE A GRIEVANCE
UNDER THAT MAKE SURE WELL ARGUE
THAT JUST BECAUSE WASN'T NET AND
MAKE SURE THAT THE WORD GETS
THEIR JOB BACK TYPICALLY.
MUCH MUCH MUCH FASTER THAN THEY
DO ON OUR STATE ENFORCEMENT SO
THERE ARE DIFFERENT WAYS TO GO
ABOUT IT SOME OF IT PROBABLY
INVOLVES JUST A SIMPLE SOLUTION
LIKE GREATER FUNDING TO ENFORCE
EXISTING LAW --
IN ADDITION ENCOURAGING MORE
WORKERS ONE WAY OR ANOTHER TO
JOIN UNIONS BUT IT IS SOMETHING
THAT HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET INTO
THE WEEDS OF IN THIS TASK FORCE
AND FIGURE OUT.
HOW WE CAN DO BETTER TO MAKE
SURE BECAUSE IT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE HEAR ABOUT OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN FROM A LOT OF
WORKERS OUT THERE?
IN IN MISCARRY TO THAT POINT I
MEAN DITION TO CLARIFYING
SIMPLIFYING THE RULES MAKE THEM
CONSISTENT. TO THE POINT OF I
THE REDUCE THE FEAR RETALIATION
ARE ACTUALLY PRODUCING ACTUAL
RETALIATION.
OF MOBILE WHAT ARE SOME THINGS
THAT YOU THINK THE LEGISLATURE
CAN DO YEAH --
I MEAN SO A LOT THAT I SEE ARE
TWO THINGS ONE IS THE NOTICE
BOTH TO EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES
ALL THE SURVEYS I'VE SEEN IS
EMPLOYEES ALWAYS REPORT THAT THE
NUMBER ONE PLACE TO HEAR FROM
ABOUT THE RIGHT IS FROM THEIR
EMPLOYERS.
EMPLOYER SIMPLY AREN'T EDUCATED
ON WHAT THESE ARE AND IT'S NOT
THAT THEY'RE ALWAYS DOING THE
WRONG THING OF COURSE I SEE THAT
HAVE ANY EVEN WHEN THEY KNOW THE
RIGHT THING BUT I'M.
WITH THE SAN FRANCISCO PAID
READILY VERNON'S WE DID A LOT
AND WE HAD WHEN FIVE HUNDRED AND
IN A WHERE WE ACTUALLY GOT ALL
THESE LAWS AND PROVIDE REAL
GUIDANCE AND I THINK WE'VE SEEN --
THE ENFORCEMENT GOAL MUCH MORE
SMOOTHLY IN THE CITY BECAUSE OF
THAT -- AND
THEN WHICH I FOUND ITS
ENFORCEMENT RIGHT NOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING WHICH ENFORCES THE
JOB PROTECTION AND THE ANTI
RETALIATION PROVISIONS --
IF YOU FILE WHAT THEY CALL PRE
COMPLAINING COREY HERE WAITING
AT LEAST THREE MONTHS FOR AN
INTAKE INTERVIEW TO FILE A
COMPLAINT AND THEN IT'S A YEAR
FROM THE FILING OF THAT
COMPLAINTS.
THAT YOU ANY DETERMINATION IS
USUALLY REACHED --
NOW THAT I THINK IS A FUNDING
PROBLEM AND STAFFING AND HOW
MANY PEOPLE THEY HAVE TO DO IN
TAKES BUT YOU KNOW THAT'S THE
PROBLEM.
AND I HAVE A COUPLE OF THE MEAT
FIRST TURNED OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUES FOR I HAVE A COUPLE
OF THINGS --
IS BECAUSE ALSO.
SO MY QUESTION IS DO WITH INCOME
REPLACEMENT OF FIGURE --
SO I HEAR YOU AND AND SHARE YOUR
CONCERNS ABOUT --
SIMPLY REPLACING INCOME AT THE
BENEFIT OF AN EMPLOYER THAT NO
LONGER HAS TO REPLACE THAT
INCOME FOR HIGHER WAGE WORKERS
[inaudible]
BUT IS THERE A WAY --
TO INCOME REPLACEMENT BY --
BY SALARY E. R..
SO THAT WE COULD DO A 100%
REPLACEMENT MAYBE FOR MINIMUM
WAGE WORKERS AND AND CHAIR IT
DOWN AS PEOPLE MAKE MORE SO IT'S
MORE OF A LIVING WAGE
REPLACEMENT.
SURE I I CAN THINK OF ANY REASON
WHY WE COULDN'T DO THAT OF
ESPECIALLY ANSWERING THAT WE DID
A VERSION OF THAT AND AB NINE
AWAY SO IT WOULD BE SOMETHING TO
TAKE A LOOK AT IT ALSO MIGHT BE
INTERESTING TO TRY TO FIND OUT
MORE ABOUT WHICH EMPLOYERS.
COORDINATE BENEFITS AS FAR AS I
KNOW IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT'S
BEEN VERY THOROUGHLY STUDIED --
BUT IT WOULD BE GOOD TO HAVE
MORE DATA ON WHOSE MOST AFFECTED
BY THAT THAN ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE
SUGGESTS WITH THAT IT WOULD BE
MUCH HIGHER INCOME WORKERS THAT.
THE INTENDED BENEFIT FROM THAT
KIND OF EMPLOYER POLICY BUT I
DON'T KNOW THAT WE CAN SAFELY
SAY THAT'S THE CASE ACROSS THE
BOARD.
BUT LEARNING MORE ABOUT WHAT
THAT EMPLOYER PROFILE LOOKS LIKE
THE ONES THAT TYPICALLY DO OFFER
COORDINATED BENEFITS WOULD BE
REALLY HELPFUL THING IN ADDITION.
TO OTHER MEASURES LIKE A
DISCUSSION AND I AGREE I MEAN
I'VE NEVER HAD SO MUCH SUPPORT
FROM LARGE EMPLOYERS FOR OF
WORKER PROTECTION AS INCOME FOR
EACH PLACEMENT WHICH SUGGESTS TO
ME THERE'S SOME OTHER THINGS
GOING ON BUT I AM THAT.
I AM TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE ARE
POSSIBLE SOLUTIONS TO IF THIS IS
THE THE PROBLEM THAT WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT IT IS
SUBSIDIZING LARGE EMPLOYERS WHO
SHOULD BE PAYING FOR THEMSELVES --
IT IS I ATE MY OBSESSION WITH
ENSURING THAT LOW WAGE WORKERS
ACTUALLY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
THAT PAYING MORE TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE THAT TIME OFF THERE ARE
THERE ARE YOU PAID FOR IT. FOR A
LOT OF OTHER FOLKS TO BE TAKING
THAT TIME OFF SO --
THEIR THEIR POSSIBLE SOLUTIONS
BESIDES NOT ADDRESSING THAT THE
PERCENT OF THE INCOME
REPLACEMENT PERCENTAGE THAT WE
COULD PROBABLY FIND YOU AGREE TO
THAT.
ABSOLUTELY.
A SIMILAR REVERSE SERGEANTS
WHERE.
AND AND OF FOLLOW UP ON THAT
MISSING GEHRY IN TERMS OF THE
EMPLOYER COMMUNITY AND SOMETIMES
WE HEAR IS DISRUPTIVE FOR
DIFFICULT TO ACCOMMODATE.
OF THESE KINDS OF THESE BUT I I
BUT STUDIES SHOW THE OPPOSITE
THAT COST WAY MORE UP TO FIVE
TIMES MORE TO HIRE A NEW.
EMPLOYEE THAN TO ACTUALLY COMPLY
WITH THE LEAVE AND ANY THOUGHTS
ON THAT OR IS THAT CONSISTENT.
TO YOUR KNOWLEDGE ON THIS YES
THE CONSISTENT WITH ALL THIS
THEIR ABC SEEN SENSE FMLA WENT
INTO A FACT YOU KNOW WHICH IS A
FEDERAL LAW PROVIDING FOR THE
TWELVE WEEKS UNPROTECTED.
JOB PREDICTED UNPAID LEAVE SORRY --
AND ALSO THE PAID FAMILY LEAVE
PROGRAM.
IT HAS BEEN OVERWHELMING
REPORTED THAT IT'S HAD EITHER
POSITIVE OR NO EFFECT ON
EMPLOYERS --
PROVIDING THIS LEAVE AMAZING AT
IMMEDIATE GUT REACTION THAT THIS
CAN'T BE DONE BUT WE SEE IT
HAPPENING ALL THE TIME AND YOU
KNOW IN SAN FRANCISCO WE ALSO AS
PART OF MY WORK I HELPED LEAD
THE HEALTHY MOTHERS WORKPLACE
COALITION.
WHICH AWARDS EMPLOYERS --
AWARDS EVERY YEAR FOR
VOLUNTARILY IMPLEMENTING FAMILY
FRIENDLY WORKPLACE POLICIES AND
WE HAVE A GOLD AWARD WINNERS AND
MANY THAT ARE SMALL EMPLOYERS.
THAT ARE PROVIDING UP TO SIX
MONTHS OF LEAVE AND THEY'RE
GETTING IT DONE --
WE KNOW IT'S POSSIBLE WE WE
SUPPORTED AND YOU KNOW ALSO IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH I THINK MANY
PEOPLE FORGET AS WE WE DO HAVE
PREGNANCY DISABILITY LEAVE LAW
WHICH ACTUALLY APPLIES TO ALL
EMPLOYERS WITH AT LEAST FIVE
EMPLOYEES.
AND PROVIDE THAT AS LONG AS
EMPLOYERS FIVE EMPLOYEES YOU
MUST PROVIDE UP TO FOUR MONTHS
OF JOB PROTECTED BUT ON PAID
TIME OFF.
WHILE YOU'RE CONSIDERED DISABLED
BY PREGNANCY CHILDBIRTH OR
RELATED CONDITION THAT'S BEEN IN
PLACE SINCE THE SEVENTIES AND
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A THRIVING
ECONOMY SELF.
I THINK IT'S PLAYED HELP THAT
THIS KIND.
IT IS A BENEFIT ACTUALLY TO
EMPLOYERS THANK YOU THE DOCTOR
CHAN'S --
YOU'D MENTION ONE THING ABOUT.
THE RECOMMENDATION IS THAT.
THE PAY THE BONTA PERCENT AND
AND TO THAT POINT MEAN WHETHER
SIXTY OR SEVENTY WEATHER'S.
HUNDRED THAT I SIXTY OR 70% YOU
STILL HAVE THE FINANCIAL
PRESSURE.
THAT LEADS TO OTHER.
KIND OF ISSUES TRAUMA OR JUST
CHALLENGES --
WHY PEOPLE DON'T TAKE LEAVE IT
ALL SO THE DIFFERENCE IS 63% AND
NOT TAKING LEAVE IT ALL WHICH IS
WHERE THEY KEEP UNDER PERCENT --
AND AND AND YOU MENTIONED THE
POST PARTUM DEPRESSION.
AND WE HAD OF UNFORTUNATE CASE
RELATIVELY RECENTLY IN SAN JOSE
WHERE A MOTHER KILLED HER.
THERE ARE TWO YOUNG BOYS INNER
SELF AND BUT WAS LINKED TO POST
PARTUM DEPRESSION AND SHE WAS
SHE WORKED EN EL SALON AND WAS
THE PRIMARY BREADWINNER.
AND I CAN OF ALWAYS.
THINK ABOUT YOU KNOW THE
CONSEQUENCES OF NOT ACTING WHEN
IT COMES TO TAKING CARE OF THE
YOUNG PARENTS YOUNG MOTHERS.
TAKING CARE OF THESE CHILDREN
AND I JUST YOU KNOW WHAT THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THAT IT JUST
KIND OF JOG MY MEMORY OF IT --
BECAUSE I THINK THAT YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S ANECDOTAL BUT
OBVIOUSLY THAT MAY NOT BE THE
END RESULT YOU KNOW THE THE
TRAGEDY IN THAT CASE BUT IT DOES
CAUSE TRAUMA.
A IN SOME CASES WITH YOUNG
MOTHERS AND CAUSES TRAUMA BUT
THE CHILDREN OF THEY'RE NOT WITH
THEIR PARENTS --
WE SO MEAN AGAIN WE SEE AN
EXTREME EXTREME CASES OF THAT
WAS HAPPENING AT THE BORDER.
AS WELL WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
SEPARATE A CHILD --
FORCING A PERIOD TIME BUT I
IMAGINE THAT ON A SMALLER LESS --
SEVERE SCALE BUT THAT SEPARATION
AT A VERY YOUNG AGE FOR LONG
PERIODS OF TIME LONG PERIODS OF
THE DAY.
I IMAGINE WOULD HAVE SOME LONG
LASTING IMPACTS IN TERMS THE
CHILD'S DEVELOPMENT.
YEAH I'VE I'D REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS AND YOUR
SENTIMENTS AND THAT'S WHY I
HEALTH ORGANIZATIONS ARE SO
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL --
THIS IS THE INTERSECTION BETWEEN
WORKING CONDITIONS.
INCOME AND HEALTH OUTCOMES IN
THE MOST CRITICAL PERIOD OF LIFE
THERE'S NO OTHER POLICY THAT'S
LIKE THIS AND THERE'S NO
INEQUITY THE UNITED STATES.
THAT AS DISPARATE AS WHAT I SEE
IN MY PEDIATRIC CLINIC RIGHT NOW
WE HAVE HIGH WAGE EARNERS WHO
ARE ABLE TO TAKE AT LEAST SIX
MONTHS TO PAY PARENTAL LEAVE.
AND THERE'S SOME LOW WAGE.
WORKERS WHO FEEL PRESSURE TO GO
BACK TO WORK IMMEDIATELY AND DO
NEED TO GO BACK TO YOU
IMMEDIATELY WHEN I LOOK AT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE SIXTY
BABY WHO NEEDS TO GO.
TO INFORMAL DAYCARE A SIX WEEK.
A SIXTY BABY SIX WITH BABY IS
SIX MONTHS EQUITY STARTS AND
THIS IS WHY SO MANY CALIFORNIANS
ARE READY. TO MAKE THIS
INVESTMENT RIGHT NOW FOR A
PARENTAL LEAVE SO THANK YOU FOR
ELEMENTS THOUGHT THAT WAY I I
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR PASS ON
THIS I REALLY DO APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR RECOGNIZING.
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS --
SO WE HAVE SOME TIME FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT IF ANYONE WOULD LIKE --
TO COME ON UP AND I WANT TO
THANK OUR PANELISTS HERE --
BOTH THE PANELS.
OF FRESH GETTING US AND AND
OFFERING YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS
AND IF UP PALACE IF YOU CAN --
OFFER COMMENTS FOR A MINUTE OR
LESS I I'D APPRECIATE THAT.
AND YEAH.
IT WAS AT THE MALL THE
MICROPHONE OVER HERE RIGHT.
NOW [inaudible]
YEAH.
HELLO MY NAME'S TONY GOMEZ I'M
HERE WITH A CALIFORNIA WORKING
FAMILY COALITION I ALSO HAVE THE
HONOR OF SERVING AS A
COMMISSIONER ON THE OAKLAND
AGING COMMISSION.
SO JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE LA --
REPORT THAT SHOWS THAT --
UP TAKE FOR I HAD CARE AND
BONDING IS ACTUALLY GOING DOWN
AND CARE GIVING IS ACTUALLY
GOING UP FOR THOSE WHO TAKE UP
FAMILY PAID LEAVE.
SO JUST REALLY HIGHLIGHTING
THOSE --
REALLY IMPORTANT CARE GIVERS TO
PLAY AN INTEGRAL ROLE IN MAKING
SURE THAT OUR AGING AND LONG
TERM CARE SYSTEM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
IS ABLE TO HELP OUR SENIORS AGE
WITH DIGNITY AND GRACE SO I'M
JUST MAKING SURE WE CONSIDER
THOSE THAT THOSE FACTS AS WE
MOVE FORWARD WITH ANY POLICY ON
FAMILY PAID LEAVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M ON I COMMITTEES --
WITH EARLY EDGE CALIFORNIA WERE
IN OREGON TO IMPROVE --
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES FOR
CHILDREN AGES BIRTH TO AGE --
FIVE AND WE JUST WANTED TO SAY
HOW SUPPORT OF WE ARE OF THE
CONCEPT OF EXPANDING LEAVE
BECAUSE THIS DOCTOR CHAN SAID --
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO HI
IMPROVING CHILDREN'S READING IS
FOR PRESCHOOL AND FOR
KINDERGARTEN ENTRY IT'S ALSO
HUGE EQUITY ISSUE PARTICULARLY
FOR TO ALL LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND
IN THEIR FIRST FEW MONTHS OF
LIFE THEY CAN BE --
EXPERIENCING THEIR HOME LANGUAGE
AND THEIR HOME CULTURE BEFORE
MOVING INTO MAY BE MORE OF A
ENGLISH LANGUAGE BASED SETTING.
THANK YOU.
HI ALEX TO CAPRI ON BEHALF OF
FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S PAID
FAMILY LEAVE PROPOSAL AND
BECAUSE PAVE AT PARENTAL LEAVE
IS NOT A LUXURY IT'S AMERICA --
MAJOR BIOLOGICAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL BENEFIT FOR EACH
CHILD AND RESEARCH MAKES IT
CLEAR THE FIRST MONTHS AND YEARS
ARE CRITICAL TO MY SUCCESS.
AND OVER 80% OF A CHILD'S BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT HAPPENS IN THE FIRST
THREE YEARS AND FREQUENT
NURTURING PARENT CHILD
INTERACTIONS ARE KEY TO STRONG
BRAIN DEVELOPMENT AND THE FIRST
THREE MONTHS --
SO WORKING PARENTS MUST HAVE THE
ABILITY TO SPEND THE FIRST
MONTHS OF EACH CHILD'S LIFE
ESTABLISHING A FOUNDATION FOR
EACH CHILD SUCCESS --
AND NO PARENT SHOULD HAVE TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN THE WELL BEING OF
THEIR NEW CHILD AND THEIR
FAMILIES FINANCIAL SECURITY AND
IS THE FIRST BY SUPPLIED THE
GOVERNOR'S --
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THEM AS A BUDGET PROGRESSES
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON IN A WIDER HER
WELL WITH A. R. P. CALIFORNIA --
JUST BEFORE I BEGIN OF COURSE WE
APPRECIATE WITH THE GOVERNOR IS
TRYING TO DO.
I WON'T ARGUE WITH EVIDENCE
BASED POLICY PROPOSALS AND WE
HAVE ENOUGH RESEARCH TO SHOW HOW.
IMPORTANT EARLY CHILDHOOD BOND
FUND ON THE ISSUE OF FAMILY CARE
GIVING WHICH OF COURSE YOU'VE
HEARD ABOUT HERE --
I'M WHAT WE HOPE IS IN FUTURE
YEARS WE'LL HAVE SOME
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW WE CAN
HELP OUR FAMILY CARE GIVERS OF
WHICH WE HAVE NEARLY FOUR AND A
HALF MILLION IN CALIFORNIA.
AN AVERAGE OF SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS OUT OF POCKET EVERY YEAR
ON THEIR LOVED ONE ON AVERAGE.
ON MY HOPE THAT WE CAN HAVE SOME
AGAIN FUTURE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
HOW WE EXPAND JOB PROTECTIONS --
WAGE REPLACEMENT RATES THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
AND AND MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
DOING MORE FOR A FAMILY CARE
GIVERS WHAT I DO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT BECAUSE YOU PROBABLY.
HEARD US SAY THIS DATA BEFORE.
THERE'S GOING TO COME A TIME
WHERE WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH CARE
GIVERS YOU'RE GOING TO YOU'RE
GOING TO GO FROM A RATIO OF
SEVEN TO ONE PAID AND UNPAID IN
TWENTY TEN TO THREE TO ONE BY
TWENTY FIFTY SO WE REALLY NEED
TO BE THINKING.
WHO'S GOING TO TAKE A NAP THAT
POSITION THE ONE CHILD THE ONE
SIBLING --
SO WE REALLY DO NEED TO A
STRANGER PROTECTIONS FOR FAMILY
CAREGIVERS TO PREPARE FOR AN
AGING POPULATION THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MARC CURTIS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE WE APPRECIATE THE
HEARING ON THIS ISSUE AND WE
APPRECIATE THE CONTINUE DIALOGUE
ON THIS ISSUE.
AND OUR ONLY CONCERN OBVIOUSLY
FROM THE EMPLOYER COMMUNITY
WOULD BE ADDITIONAL POTENTIAL
LITIGATION THAT MIGHT STEM FROM
THE DETAILS OF THE PROPOSALS BUT
AGAIN WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE ONE TO
LET YOU KNOW THANKS.
THANK YOU.
CAN I INTERVENE AND SAY I THINK
IT'S PARTICULARLY CRUEL FOR THE
CHAMBER TO SEND A PREGNANT WOMAN --
TO CONCERNS ABOUT ACTED LEAVE.
THAT IS AYE AYE THAT IS MY
PROBLEM TO VISIT MEMBER AT
ALWAYS AGREE TO DISAGREE BUT
THEY HAVE TAKEN IT TOO FAR NOW.
I HOPE YOU HAVE JOB PROTECTED
LEAVE IF NOT --
I I HEARD THEY HAVE REALLY GOOD
PAY LEAVE IN THE CHAMBER.
WE SHOULD ALL LOOK INTO THAT IS
ONE OF THE HELPING FAMILY
EMPLOYERS.
MY NAME IS JENNY CASSIDY I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
WORKING FAMILY COALITION AND I
JUST REALLY WANT A HIGH IT KIND
OF YOU KNOW PUT AN EXCLAMATION
POINT BY ALL THE THINGS I'VE
HEARD MY COLLEAGUE SAID HERE
TODAY -- YOU
KNOW SINCE WE PASSED A LEAVE IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWO IMPLEMENTED IN.
TWO THOUSAND FOR A LOT OF OUR
WORKING CALIFORNIA IS REALLY
MAKING IT WORK BETTER --
FOR THE MAJORITY OF FAMILIES
WHICH ARE REALLY LOW INCOME
STRUGGLING FAMILIES JUST A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
COLLEAGUES ABOUT MINE AND I WERE
IN FRESNO MEETING WITH
FARMWORKERS WHO ARE PAYING IN TO
STI AND SAY GET PAID FAMILY
LEAVE.
BUT SO MANY DIFFERENT THINGS
INCLUDING A TEXAN NOT BEING
HIRED BACK THE NEXT SEASON.
SO I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF WORK%
TO DO IS WE REALLY APPLIED WHAT
THE GOVERNOR'S DOING MOVING US
FORWARD.
THAT WE STILL HAVE THAT PART OF
HOW WE REALLY MAKE THIS WORK FOR
EVERYBODY SO WE'RE NOT JUST
MOVING FORWARD FOR ONE SECTION.
AND EVERYBODY ELSE IS LEFT
BEHIND SO THAT REALLY IS SHOP
PROTECTION IT'S NOT IT'S WAITED
PLACEMENT BUT IT'S ALSO JOB
PROTECTION.
AND THEN I THINK ALSO WITH THE
EDT WE'VE WORKED ON SOME OF THAT
HELP REACH.
NOT JUST THE ADS IN THE THIS AND
THAT BUT REALLY HAVING IN SOME
COMMUNITIES HANDS ON PEOPLE WHO
HAVE THE EDUCATION AND NOT
ALWAYS JUST EMPLOYERS SOME
PLAYERS YES BUT TRUSTED
MESSENGERS TO SO THOSE ARE THE
PIECES THAT WE REALLY WANT TO BE.
WORKING ON A LONG SIDE WITH
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE STATE
THIS YEAR THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY ENGRAM ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
APPRECIATIVE OF THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION THAT WAS HAD HERE
TODAY.
AND LOOK AT SUPPORTING PROPOSALS
AND IN FAVOR OF EXTENDING THE
DURATION OF LEAVE EXTENDING JOB
PROTECTIONS TO ALIGN WITH PAID
LEAVE AS MODELS MAKING SURE THAT
PROGRAMS ARE TRULY XSL FILE BY
LOW INCOME WORKERS.
LÏNG A WORKERS WITH LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENCY AND ALSO
STATE WORKERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY FINAL COMMENTS FROM NINE
MEMBERS.
WELL ONE OF THE BANK OF THE SAME
MEMBERS WERE PARTICIPATING IN
BEING HERE TODAY I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE PANELISTS --
THIS IS VERY HELPFUL AND I THINK
THE BEGINNING OF OF WHAT I
IMAGINE WILL BE MANY
CONVERSATIONS.
ON THE DETAILS BECAUSE I THINK
THAT --
GENERALLY SPEAKING --
OF THESE FROM THE ASSEMBLY THE
POSITION OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL I THINK IT ALIGNS WITH
A LOT OF OUR PRIORITIES.
OF OF COURSE BE ABLE TO PAY FOR
IT AND SOME OF LOGISTICS HOW TO
ACTUALLY.
OPERATE IT OR ARE GOING TO BE
THE CHALLENGE AND THAT'S WHY
THIS CONVERSATION.
EARLIER RATHER THAN LATER --
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER IS
REALLY IMPORTANT I WANT TO THANK
AS A MEMBER COOPER --
MOBILE FOR ABOUT THE JOINING OF
THE LABOR COMMITTEE AND UP.
HOLDING THIS INFORMATION HERE
AND I HOPE WE CAN WORK TOGETHER
ON SIMILAR HEARINGS LIKE THIS IN
THE FUTURE AND I WANT TO THANK
KATY HARTMAN --
AND THE STAFF OF FOUR ASSEMBLY
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR OF FOUR
PEOPLE WORKING WITH US TO MAKE
THIS HEARING A POSSIBLE SO THANK
YOU ALL SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE